de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
madame merci nous vous écoutons pour une
introduction si vous souhaitiez nous
dire quelques mots préliminaires et
après quoi Monsieur le rapporteur et mes
collègues et moi-même vous poseront
certains de questions
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de l'occasion
qui nous est donnée aujourd'hui
d'intervenir devant votre commission
d'enquête j'interviens donc devant vous
en qualité de directrice générale des
opérations pour la France mais également
pour le Benelux et l'Europe du Sud avant
de rejoindre l'entreprise j'ai travaillé
pendant 12 ans chez Disney dans des
fonctions commerciales et marketing et
plus récemment j'étais en charge de la
direction commerciale pour le comité
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024
ce qui m'a conduit chez Tik Tok c'est le
souhait de retrouver le secteur des
médias du divertissement et de
participer au développement de la
plateforme en France
Tik Tok est à la pointe de l'innovation
et a connu une croissance extrêmement
rapide sur ces cinq dernières années
comme tout changement cela suscite des
interrogations et c'est donc avec un
esprit de coopération et de transparence
que je souhaite aborder cette audition
aujourd'hui
Tic-Toc est donc une application de
divertissement qui rassemble des
millions d'utilisateurs 22 millions en
France en l'occurrence effectivement
qui leur permet de partager leur
quotidien leur culture leur passion
d'apprendre de se divertir de découvrir
le monde et de se connecter les uns aux
autres autour de centres d'intérêt
commun
depuis notre lancement c'est le sens de
la responsabilité qui nous anime la
responsabilité de d'offrir le meilleur
contenu possible dans un espace sur et
inclusif
et c'est et c'est très important pour
nous parce que on pense que ce travail
continue nous permet de proposer une
plateforme créative qui contribue au
dynamisme de notre société et qui sert
de tremplin à Bondon d'acteurs culturels
économiques et finalement à tous les
utilisateurs
c'est de la confiance envers
l'application que découle nos capacités
à fidéliser nos utilisateurs et donc en
supprimant les contenus qui sont
contraires à nos valeurs et en modérant
effectivement ces comportements
malveillants et c'est également la même
mécanique pour les annonceurs et donc
c'est ce qui nous permet de fidéliser
nos annonceurs et de générer des revenus
et on peut dire aujourd'hui que la
plupart des grandes marques des grandes
entreprises sont présentes sur la
plateforme que ce soit à travers des
comptes organiques ou à travers des
campagnes publicitaires
les équipes de Tik Tok en France ont à
cœur d'animer toutes les grandes
communautés qui sont présentes sur la
plateforme que ce soit des passionnés de
sport des passionnés de musique de
cinéma de lecture de gastronomie et
c'est souvent ce qui va motiver nos
choix à nous associer à tel ou tel
événement
et au-delà de ces de ces grands
événements nous soutenons aussi nous
créons des programmes sur des sujets
divers qui sont des programmes qui nous
paraissent importants on peut parler du
livre on peut parler de l'éducation et
je voudrais vous donner juste un exemple
un programme qui s'appelle apprendre sur
TikTok nous avons lancé avec les équipes
cette année dont l'ambition est de faire
émerger le contenu et d'encourager la
création de contenu de contenu éducatifs
des contenus qui vont parler
de sciences de culture générale de de
français de langue et aujourd'hui ce
programme rassemble près d'un milliard
de vues en France
nous avons aussi à cœur de soutenir
toutes les grandes causes
nous accompagnons l'action de nombreuses
associations
sur des sujets aussi divers que l'éveil
à l'esprit critique que sur la santé que
sur la lutte contre le harcèlement
contre les discriminations
le combat pour l'égalité est également
un sujet important pour nous et nous
serons particulièrement actifs à
l'occasion du mois des fiertés
on ne compte plus le nombre de créateurs
qui ont pu développer leur entreprise
grâce à Tik Tok ils sont plus de 5
millions aux États-Unis et probablement
autant en Europe
en France des artisans des restaurateurs
toutes sortes d'entrepreneurs créer des
contenus partagent leur passion partage
leur savoir-faire sur la plateforme et
en font un accélérateur de croissance
Tik Tok est également un acteur reconnu
de l'orientation professionnelle et de
l'élaboration des parcours
professionnels et ce n'est pas un hasard
si Pôle Emploi s'appuie sur nous à
travers ses campagnes de communication
autour de mission emploi pour en faire
la promotion
de grandes entreprises également
utilisent Tik Tok comme un outil de
marque employeur et également
pour recruter on peut citer Carrefour on
peut citer à Cork Club Med police
nationale et beaucoup d'autres les
modies emploie et recrutement totalise
chacun d'eux plus de 500 millions de
vues sur la plateforme
j'espère avoir porte apporté un
éclairage
utile à ce qui est Tik Tok les
propositions bien sûr qui émaneront de
cette commission d'enquête nous
permettront probablement d'aller plus
loin
nous pensons que cet effort néanmoins ne
peut être porté par Tik Tok uniquement
dans la mesure où un certain nombre
d'enjeux traités par votre commission
appel à une réflexion collective
qui engage sur la responsabilité plus
large de l'ensemble des plateformes je
vous remercie pour votre écoute et me
tient à vos dispositions pour vos
questions
[Musique]
avant que monsieur déroule ne serait-ce
que
comment dire je dois pas être le seul à
me poser la question qu'est-ce que fait
monsieur Garandeau que vous ne faites
pas et inversement quel est vous votre
votre rôle pour le qu'on puisse
l'expliquer aux gens qui nous écoutent
donc mon rôle en fait les opérations
c'est la responsabilité finalement de
faire grandir l'écosystème sur le marché
français et en l'occurrence sur les
autres marchés que que dont j'ai la
responsabilité aussi ce que ça veut dire
c'est accompagner un certain nombre de
créateurs de personnalités publiques et
de marques à prendre la parole sur la
plateforme donc en fait on va leur
donner des bonnes pratiques on va les
donner leur donner un certain nombre de
conseils en matière de
durée des vidéos de fréquence de
publication de à quel moment prendre la
parole de quelle stratégie éditoriale
pourrait être intéressantes tout en leur
laissant toute la liberté puisque
finalement
Erica rando a précisé ce matin
on est on n'est pas dans un rôle
d'éditeur nous ne sommes pas éditeurs
nous restons une plateforme donc on
reste dans notre rôle finalement de
diffuseur de ces messages mais chaque
marque est bien sûr autonome sur sa
stratégie éditoriale et ses messages
donc le rôle mon rôle est celui de mes
équipes ça va être d'accompagner
finalement tous ces grands acteurs à
mieux comprendre ce qu'est la plateforme
et en faire le meilleur usage possible
eric Garandeau pour sa part lui
travaille sur des sujets d'affaires
publiques donc il est en relation avec
le monde public pour toutes les
questions qui s'y réfèrent
merci monsieur le Président merci
d'avoir madame d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
je voulais vous poser une première
question est-ce que vous connaissez
madame Zao Tian non je ne la connais pas
vous savez que c'est votre présidente
écoutez je effectivement je sais que
c'est la présidente d'un point de vue
juridique mais je ne l'ai jamais
rencontré
est-ce que vous savez s'il a déjà mis
les pieds en France
alors comme je voulais peut-être pas dit
on préambule mais j'ai rejoint
l'entreprise il y a un an enfin si le
président m'a précisé j'ai rejoint
l'entreprise en mars 2022 donc je reste
assez récente dans mon rôle donc je
pourrais pas vous parler de ce qui s'est
passé avant mars 2022 en l'occurrence
depuis mars 2022 elle ne nous a pas
rendu visite dans nos bureaux de Paris
alors Monsieur Garandeau nous a dit ce
matin qu'il n'avait jamais rencontré
donc depuis 2020 elle n'est pas venue en
France est-ce que vous trouvez normal
que les deux directeurs principaux de
Tik Tok France n'est jamais rencontré la
présidente
je crois que son rôle en fait se limite
à un rôle de représentante d'un point de
vue légal et juridique je ne suis
absolument pas une experte de ces
sujets-là malheureusement
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que mon
patron direct est à Londres
Erica rando la préciser ce matin son nom
est rich waterworth et les directives
les directions que je reçois en matière
de stratégie sur les opérations
viennent de viennent de Londres
alors madame Zao Tiane et non seulement
présidente de
Tik Tok France et président de tik
tokyoquet mais elle est aussi
vice-présidente de tout Yao vous avez
sans doute entendu parler
tout Yao c'est une des filiales de ce
qui s'appelait by dance Chine et qui
maintenant s'appelle douille
les responsables de Tik Tok Etats-Unis
caïman France quai etc ont toujours dit
qu'il n'y avait aucun lien
entre
Tik Tok et douille et que tout était
séparé
est-ce que vous
ne trouvez pas que le fait que Madame
tchao tient soit président de plusieurs
sociétés Tik Tok et en même temps
président d'une filiale chinoise de
Douillet infirme cette déclaration alors
on a eu l'occasion de regarder en plus
que vous avez posé la question ce matin
et
manifestement l'information comme quoi
et les présidents tout vice-président de
tout Yao n'est pas correct donc je vous
propose de revenir vers vous sur ce
point mais mais en tout cas c'est pas
l'information qu'on a à nous moi ce que
je peux vous dire sur Tian Zaho c'est
qu'effectivement elle semble occuper un
poste
sur les sujets d'éthique et de
conformité et que probablement mais
encore une fois je n'étais pas là et là
endossé une responsabilité à la création
de la structure juridique au moment où
les équipes étaient en recrutement je
peux pas tellement vous en dire plus que
je sais aussi c'est que c'est pas
complètement une anomalie c'est à dire
que pour beaucoup d'entreprises
internationales qui opère en France le
responsable juridique n'est pas
nécessairement celui qui gère les
opérations
mais je vais pas pouvoir vous en dire
beaucoup plus malheureusement
[Musique]
utiliser du mal à venir en France et que
ils ne sont pas à notre disposition mais
nous pouvions tout à fait c'est ce que
nous avons proposé de le faire par vidéo
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez une ce
que vous savez si cette demande
d'audition sera honorée d'une façon ou
d'une autre ou non je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas on peut effectivement
évidemment nous assurer que
l'information soit bien passée et qu'on
revienne vers vous très vite on l'a
demandé déjà il y a pas mal de temps
et la Commission du siège pas
indéfiniment
merci beaucoup alors je voulais vous
poser une question concernant
le DSA
les grandes plateformes jusqu'à la fin
août pour mettre se mettre en conformité
avec le DSA de ce que nous constatons
dans le cadre de l'enquête Tik Tok
semble loin d'être aujourd'hui en
conformité par exemple sur la
compatibilité des transferts de données
avec le rgpd sur le contrôle de l'âge
des utilisateurs
et vous devrez vous mettre en conformité
très très vite maintenant dans moins de
deux mois
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquer si
à la fin août Tik Tok sera en mesure de
ce conformer au DSA et si en ce qui
concerne ce qui n'est pas encore
conforme dans quel délai la conformité
peut être attendue je prends un exemple
le profilage des mineurs a des fins
publicitaires sera interdit dans le DSA
ce profilage des mineurs aujourd'hui sur
Tik Tok il est
je voudrais pas être méchant mais enfin
il est pratiquement inexistant c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de profilage
certains des mineurs il n'y a pas de de
mécanisme certains les
signalements d'utilisateurs sont
évidemment quelque chose de très
embryonnaire en matière de ce qu'il
faudrait et le seul les seules
possibilités sont ce qui est proposé par
certains
experts du type carte bancaire ou du
type double anonymisation pour comme
pour les sites pornographiques c'est ce
qui est proposé mais pour les sites
pornographiques je pense que c'est
proposer un peu ils ont un peu plus de
temps donc il y a des solutions mais ces
solutions aujourd'hui ne sont pas du
tout du tout utilisées par Tik Tok qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas la seule à avoir ce
problème est-ce que vous pensez que
d'ici le mois d'août ce problème sera
résolu que vous auriez vous aurez un
profil
une certitude de l'âge des utilisateurs
en tout cas au moins de du caractère que
mineur ou non des utilisateurs
alors sur le sujet du DSA on est
effectivement extrêmement confiant dans
notre capacité à être en conformité au
mois d'août on a des équipes qui
travaillent depuis plus d'un an sur le
sujet qui sont mobilisés dessus on a
d'ailleurs des échanges avec la
Commission européenne sur le sur le
sujet des travaux préparatoires des
réunions préparatoires donc en tout cas
à ma connaissance aucune inquiétude sur
notre capacité à être conforme sur votre
point qui est le sujet du ciblage on a
aujourd'hui très peu d'annonceurs en
fait qui cible sur des mineurs on est
déjà aujourd'hui
dans le respect finalement de
d'une non publicité sur les moins de 15
ans donc on a déjà évidemment adressé ce
sujet là ce sujet de la majorité
numérique
aujourd'hui les annonceurs ne viennent
pas sur la plateforme pour communiquer
sur les plus jeunes c'est absolument pas
le le gros de nos investissements de nos
revenus publicitaires nos revenus
publicitaires adressent bien du 18 plus
donc on est absolument pas inquiet sur
cette
euh sur cette mise en conformité en tout
cas sur le sujet du du profiling euh
du profiling en tout cas sur le ciblage
publicitaire
et bien sûr que ça fera partie des
choses sur lesquelles on ajustera et
finalement c'est pas le plus compliqué
entre entre guillemets de d'ajuster de
se mettre en conformité sur des sujets
de stratégie publicitaires
sur le DSA donc on n'a pas de raison
d'être inquiet à ce stade et puis après
au-delà de pour moi à ma connaissance le
sujet de profiling concerne le ciblage
des campagnes publicitaires le sujet de
la vérification de l'âge et est un autre
est un autre point et bien sûr je crois
savoir que l'acnil et l'arcom travaille
d'arrache-pied sur aussi une solution
qui pourrait être
utile pour toute le toute la profession
et notre enjeu et et notre souhait est
d'être en conformité avec les solutions
qui seront proposées
sur l'âge c'est à la plateforme de
prouver qu'elle fait respecter le droit
c'est pas l'arcom qui va avec ses
petites mains et en payant des
ingénieurs à votre place proposer des
solutions comme ça que ça marche non
bien sûr bien sûr non mais on vérifie
bien sûr déjà aujourd'hui l'âge je peux
effectivement détailler tout ce qu'on
fait en matière d'âge mais ma
compréhension était que dans la mesure
où de nouvelles lois sont en préparation
sur un
contrôle plus avéré
principe de edgegateing là dessus bien
sûr pardon de vérification de l'âge bien
sûr que l'idée est d'être en conformité
avec les solutions qui seront proposées
par l'acnil et l'arcom sur le sujet de
la vérification de l'âge c'est un sujet
extrêmement important pour nous vous
l'avez probablement vu passer dans les
réponses qu'on a fait dans le
questionnaire mais Tik Tok a été la
première plateforme à communiquer sur le
nombre de comptes supprimer
parce que suspecter d'être moins de 13
ans donc on a 18 millions de comptes qui
ont été supprimés sur
le dernier sur le semestre 2022 sur le
dernier trimestre 2022 pardon donc c'est
évidemment très important et pour ça on
a beaucoup d'outils on a des outils
algorithmiques qui nous permettent
d'identifier un certain nombre de choses
on a aussi des dans ces outils
algorithmiques on a la possibilité de
lire un certain d'informations qui sont
écrits dans ce qu'on appelle les
biographies donc où effectivement un
jeune va peut-être y mettre une
information de j'ai 12 ans où je fête
mes 12 ans etc on a des informations
aussi qui peuvent arriver par
signalement donc ou effectivement
quelqu'un va identifier que cette
personne a moins de à moins de 13 ans et
puis ça peut arriver aussi que sur la
modération d'un contenu en particulier
nos modérateurs parce qu'ils sont formés
à l'identification de ces de ces
de ces sujets de mineurs va identifier
qu'effectivement il pense que cette
personne a moins de 13 ans donc on a une
politique extrêmement active sur le
sujet et on prend vraiment très très au
sérieux
parmi les
articles du DSA il est dit il est très
grandes plateformes en ligne devront
faire la transparence sur leurs
algorithmes
quels sont les moyens prévus pour
permettre à la Commission européenne
d'accéder aux données de Tik Tok et
d'évaluer le respect des règlements les
API actuellement disponibles sur Tik Tok
à destination des régulateurs et des
chercheurs sont notoirement extrêmement
plus réduits que celui que ceux des
principales autres plateformes qu'est-ce
qui est prévu pour la mise en conformité
de ces dpi ne ces API avec les
recommandations du DSA
alors le les API effectivement qui sont
en train d'être développés sont à
destination de chercheurs
d'universitaires du scientifiques
d'experts qui vont permettre deux choses
un de mieux comprendre
l'outil la plateforme et il y a un
deuxième sujet qui est effectivement de
mieux comprendre nos
pratiques en termes de modération donc
le premier aspect qui en fait l'API qui
permet de mieux comprendre la plateforme
c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui qui est
en test aux États-Unis qui va arriver en
Europe dès la fin de l'année c'est un
outil qui a été bêta testé aussi par
Sciences Po donc le média là-bas donc
ces API arrivent et ces API permettront
de mettre effectivement peut-être
d'apporter un éclairage supplémentaire
sur des sujets divers qui sont peut-être
aussi des sujets de recherche comme
l'impact des campagnes publicitaires
sur voilà sur un certain nombre de
sujets donc ces API qui sont
effectivement aujourd'hui finalement
qui arrive dans un à une étape assez
logique de maturité développement de la
plateforme sont en train de se mettre en
place
alors j'ai posé ce matin une question
monsieur Garandeau je crois qu'il m'a
dit que c'était plutôt à vous qu'il
fallait la poser dans les futurs centres
de données et notamment dans le projet
Clover est-ce que vous utiliserez les
mêmes logiciels
actuels logiciel américain et
immatriculé aux États-Unis à savoir
Google cloud amazon Web Service et
Microsoft Microsoft ager
très probablement toute façon là on a
résumé quasiment toutes les solutions
Cloud du marché ou presque donc très
probablement s'appuiera sur les mêmes
solutions mais en étant absolument pas
un expert du cloud
si vous permettez je pense qu'on
demandera aux experts de revenir vers
vous précisément sur ce point alors ça
va vous poser un problème parce que si
vous utilisez ces logiciels vous êtes
soumis au Cloud Act américain et ce
cloud acte américain n'est pas
compatible n'est pas jugé compatible par
la Commission européenne avec les
règlements européens et notamment avec
le rgpd actuel et le DSA demain comment
vous allez régler ce problème
alors votre question dépasse mes
compétences je suis je suis pas une
expert technique malheureusement ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'on a des gens
qui sont très compétents en la matière
et qui pourront vous donner plus de
détails et bien sûr que on se mettra pas
à risque sur le respect ni du rgpd ni du
DSA donc tous ces sujets ont forcément
été pensés mais on vous apportera des
précisions
merci je voulais vous parler de votre
navigateur vous utilisez un navigateur
natif vous n'utilisez pas un navigateur
j'allais dire du commerce enfin un autre
navigateur vous avez votre propre
navigateur
et ce navigateur permet de surveiller je
dirais la quasi-totalité de l'activité
de l'utilisateur il est particulièrement
intrusive
vous pouvez en citera tout à l'heure
quelques-uns est-ce que vous avez ici en
tête ou sur un papier la liste des
données collectées par Tic-Toc la
navigation d'un utilisateur alors quand
vous parlez de navigation c'est
effectivement j'imagine quand on est sur
l'application et qu'on va chercher un
mot clé en particulier ou une vidéo ou
un créateur alors c'est pas l'usage
prioritaire de Tik Tok c'est en fait le
la façon dont est construit la
plateforme l'usage principal en fait les
les utilisateurs vont sur la plateforme
et en fait
dans j'imagine 98% des cas vont
consommer les vidéos qui leur sont
proposées puisque la force de Tik Tok
c'est cet algorithme qui va vous
proposer des vidéos qui correspondent à
vos centres d'intérêts donc en fait le
flux de vidéo dans le dans le fil qui
s'appelle pour toi c'est c'est le flux
de vidéos qui est la pratique courante
sur la plateforme maintenant on voit
émerger un certain nombre de tendances
notamment effectivement
ce qu'on appelle la génération Z qui est
cette capacité à chercher des des
données des contenus sur des sujets
particuliers exemple je suis en train de
visiter Taormine j'ai envie de voir
quels sont les lieux les à ne pas
manquer je vais taper dormir dans mon
moteur de recherche et je vais voir un
certain nombre de contenu apparaître
donc en fait la recherche ce qu'elle
nous donne comme information c'est c'est
cette personne est intéressée par
Taormine ou la Sicile ou par le tourisme
et de fait
cette personne l'information que ça nous
donne c'est si il se passe quelque chose
de formidable en Italie à ce moment là
où en Sicile
on va pouvoir potentiellement lui
pousser une notification pour qu'il ne
rate pas cet événement voilà à quoi sert
en fait le moteur de recherche
aujourd'hui mais c'est c'est pas du tout
la pratique courante des utilisateurs
sur Tik Tok
mais elle se développe elle se développe
oui assez naturellement parce qu'en fait
on a eu l'habitude en fait on est passé
d'une génération on allait chercher
effectivement sur Google surf je suis
une information qui était une
information texte et aujourd'hui on voit
que parce que la profondeur de contenu
est très large sur TiK ToK on peut avoir
des informations sur des restaurants sur
des lieux de visite etc donc en fait
elle se développe naturellement mais
c'est pas
c'est pas encore un complètement inscrit
dans la pratique usuelle des
utilisateurs enfin pas de tout en tout
cas pas de la majorité merci alors sur
ce navigateur sur le logiciel de base du
navigateur il est possible
d'injecter du code de Javascript pour
obtenir une granularité encore plus fine
dans le suivi de l'activité est-ce que
cette injection de code javascript est
actuellement utilisée et quels sont les
données recueillies dans ce cadre
alors des codes javascript sur le
franchement là je
j'aurais du mal à vous répondre moi ce
que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la seule façon dont on
utilise les données qu'on collecte sur
le search ce sont des données qui nous
permettent de cibler quand on va d'un
point de vue éditorial
pousser un contenu en particulier je
sais pas en France par exemple enfin je
vous redonne un autre exemple on a des
fans de jeux vidéo qui vont chercher des
informations sur sur le nouveau jeu
Zelda
ça nous donne une information que cette
personne est intéressée par les jeux
vidéo et donc peut-être c'est pas une
obligation mais si on est partenaire de
la Paris Games Week on va se dire et ben
notre groupe de d'utilisateurs qui sont
intéressés par le jeu vidéo on va leur
donner l'information que on est
partenaire de de cet événement donc en
fait c'est à des fins de finalement de
d'informations
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pourrez nous
au cas où vous découvrirez en rentrant
chez Tik Tok il y a des
une partie de code JavaScript dans la
logiciel du navigateur actuellement
est-ce que vous pourriez nous faire
savoir si c'est le cas et quels sont les
données recueillies par ce code en tout
cas personne ne code en France donc ça
c'est sûr mais effectivement je
reviendrai vers vous je on posera la
question mais j'ai pas connaissance de
ça
l'association Exodus privé si qui est
une plateforme d'Audi de la vie privée
des applications
ressentent sur Tik Tok 5 pisteurs et 44
permissions sur le téléphone
c'est un nombre considérable d'autant
que certains sont définis par Exodus
comme dangereuse
en dire assez intrusive d'après les
niveaux de protection indiqués par
Google je cite entre autres accès à la
position exacte au premier plan afficher
connexion réseau connexion Wi-Fi se
connecter aux appareils Bluetooth
associé accès à la caméra accès au
contact contenu de mémoire de stockage
partagé enregistrement de fichiers audio
il y en a 44 comme ça
ces permissions semblent beaucoup trop
nombreuses pour les besoins du service
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire celles
qui sont utiles et celles qu'ils ne sont
pas et pourquoi celles qui ne sont pas
sont-elles néanmoins demandées par
l'appli
d'autre part sur les 44 permissions
possibles seuls 16 figure sur la page
politique de confidentialité du site
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ne figure pas
toutes
et enfin dans le même paragraphe de la
politique du confidentialité figure la
phrase suivante nous pouvons également
vous associer à des renseignements
recueillis à partir d'appareils autres
que ceux que vous utilisez pour vous
connecter à la plateforme est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce que signifie
cette phrase
alors écoutez je ne connais pas cette
étude donc je n'ai pas le l'historique à
ni le contexte donc je peux pas en
mesurer le niveau de pertinence ni de
fiabilité ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que on a une transparence totale sur les
données qui sont collectées
vous avez la possibilité quand vous êtes
sur l'application de télécharger vos
données de télécharger les données qui
sont collectées donc en fait c'est très
simple on inclique vous téléchargez un
fichier et vous avez la capacité de lire
les données qui sont collectées donc ça
c'est un premier point transparence qui
est qui est vraiment très important
ensuite sur les données vous avez aussi
la possibilité de limiter ces données
collectées c'est à dire que vous avez la
possibilité sur l'application
d'enlever par exemple la
personnalisation de des publicités donc
vous avez la possibilité de décocher et
ça ça vous permet effectivement de
limiter ces données là vous avez la
possibilité aussi de
limiter le niveau de
de confidentialité de tout ce que vous
faites sur la plateforme c'est à dire
que vous pouvez décider que vos vidéos
elles sont vus uniquement par vos amis
vous avez vous allez limiter le nombre
de personnes qui vont être capables de
commenter vos vidéos donc vous avez une
capacité à être en contrôle d'une bonne
partie des données que vous allez
laisser les données qui sont qui sont
collectées c'est des données que vous
allez donner parce que c'est vous donner
d'utilisation de la plateforme et
ensuite c'est des données que vous
donnez à l'inscription sur la plateforme
et je pense que ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quand on se rend sur les sur
les stores en fait sur Google Play ou
sur l'Apple Store vous avez la
possibilité de voir quelles sont les
données qui sont collectées par chaque
plateforme et c'est intéressant de
regarder parce que vous allez voir que
Tik Tok est finalement une des
plateformes qui collecte le moins de
données donc c'est c'est important de
regarder et de remettre en perspective
aussi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
le sujet des données aujourd'hui on est
très confiant par rapport à ça parce que
encore une fois on a la capacité en tant
qu'utilisateur de télécharger les
données qui sont collectées
alors en ce qui concerne la
une deuxième question
oui
donc nous pouvons sur votre politique de
confidentialité la phrase nous pouvons
également vous associer à des
renseignements recueillis à partir
d'appareils autres que ceux que vous
utilisez pour vous connecter à la
plateforme est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire ce que ça veut dire parce que c'est
très très comme souvent d'ailleurs sur
la page de la politique de
confidentialité c'est très vague
est-ce que quelqu'un peut est-ce que les
gens qui viennent sur votre les
utilisateurs peuvent comprendre cette
phrase moi je la comprends pas et donc
ça me paraît insatisfaisant alors je
ne me permettrai pas de faire une
interprétation de cette phrase parce que
je j'ai trop de respect pour les gens
qui ont écrit cette politique donc
permettez-moi de demander aux équipes
juridiques de revenir précisément vers
vous sur ce sujet j'ai une petite idée
mais elle est probablement très
incorrecte et très très
peu complète donc je préfère qu'on
revienne vers vous avec une réponse
étayée de de la part des équipes
juridiques qui ont travaillé sur ce
texte
le Président c'est pour ne pas revenir
me faire revenir après parce que je
voudrais creuser votre question
je vous la reformule est-ce que toutes
les données collectées qu'elles soient
par la suite comment dire désamorçable
ou pas par l'utilisateur parce que les
données que vous collectez on va dire de
par principe avant que l'utilisateur
paramètres ces données sont-elles toutes
utiles
pour vivre une belle expérience
utilisateur
alors je
pense que oui je pense qu'elles sont
utiles parce que c'est beaucoup de
travail de mettre en place tous ces
outils de de pilotage et de suivi donc
j'imagine qu'elles sont toutes utiles en
tout cas
encore une fois je suis pas à la
création du produit ni de l'algorithme
donc j'ai du mal à vous répondre
précisément à cette question ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que notre enjeu
nous il est de continuer à éduquer sur
les fonctionnalités au cœur de la
plateforme qui permettent d'être en
meilleure contrôle des données qu'on
laisse et ça c'est notre enjeu parce
qu'encore une fois on est une plateforme
jeune on est récent donc on a besoin de
faire connaître tout ça et c'est aussi
ce qu'on essaye de faire on a on a un
investi beaucoup d'argent depuis depuis
octobre dernier on investit 2 millions
d'euros sur des campagnes qui expliquent
justement toutes ces fonctionnalités qui
qui répondent à des enjeux de sécurité
qui répondent à des enjeux de meilleurs
contrôles de son expérience et ça oui
c'est important que effectivement on
éduque parce que
je pense qu'on a aujourd'hui des années
de d'expérience digitales et numérique
mais on a encore besoin effectivement de
d'accompagner les utilisateurs les
parents les plus jeunes sur le bon usage
de toutes ces de toutes ces
fonctionnalités
alors comme le président a poursuivi ma
question je vais poursuivre la sienne en
prenant un certain nombre d'exemples
par exemple accès au contact sur
l'appareil n'est pas nécessaire puisque
l'appli fonctionne correctement si on le
désactive
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
est la finalité de cette permission
quelle est la nature des données
stockées est-ce que c'est numéro de
téléphone email ou toutes les
informations disponibles dans les
contacts
dont on est pas certain que eux qui ne
sont pas sur TikTok soit ravi de
communiquer à Tik Tok alors les
informations par l'intermédiaire d'un
utilisateur du Tik Tok et deuxièmement
est-ce que ces informations demeurent en
local ou est-ce que le sont transférés
transféré vers un serveur
donc à l'étranger actuellement
est-ce qu'elles sont partagées avec des
tiers et est-ce que des croisements de
données sont effectuées
alors cette cette possibilité de
connecter vos contacts c'est une
possibilité c'est à dire que moi à titre
personnel j'ai pas connecté mes contacts
de mes autres plateformes donc vous avez
le choix de le faire ou de pas le faire
et si vous le faites pas vous donner pas
ces données donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
quand même une démarche volontaire
aujourd'hui de se dire je vais me créer
un réseau d'amis plus grand en
connectant mes applications mes réseaux
voilà donc en fait il y a quand même une
démarche qui est aujourd'hui de de ça
n'est pas imposé c'est à dire qu'en fait
ça reste de l'ordre de la proposition et
chacun est libre de de le faire ou pas
après sur l'usage qui en est fait
j'essaie de réfléchir d'un point de vue
usage utilisateur la raison pour
laquelle je le ferai c'est parce que
j'ai envie de voir ce que mes amis
postent comme contenu sur la plateforme
parce qu'il y a une telle densité de
contenu sur la plateforme que votre vos
chances de voir sur le fil pour toi les
vidéos de vos amis et finalement très
faibles donc le fait de connecter vos
amis ça vous permet de faire émerger
dans votre fil dans votre flux de vidéo
des vidéos de de des personnes que vous
connaissez donc c'est fait dans une
logique particulière et c'est pas fait
dans une logique de collègues de données
c'est quand même dans une logique
d'expérience utilisateurs après sur les
données précises qui sont qui sont
collectés par
[Musique]
Tik Tok dans le cadre de cette connexion
des des contacts c'est
pardonnez-moi mais je l'ai pas
exactement tête mais c'est probablement
très bien expliqué dans notre politique
de confidentialité et je vous propose
que on vous détaille tout ça par écrit
à la suite de la de l'audition
alors vous avez expliqué en matière de
collecte de données
le téléchargement des données collectées
possibles le décochage possible etc
il y a la théorie et la pratique c'est à
dire qu'en théorie effectivement
vous avez la possibilité de télécharger
les données qui sont collectées pour
voir quelles sont ces données vous avez
possibilité de décocher donc c'est de
l'Octa ou si j'ai bien compris
le
les données qui sont
pardon le fait de donner de connecter
vos contacts ah non c'est on vous
demande si vous voulez connecter vos
contacts donc c'est le petit
et sur les sur les données dont on
parlait tout à l'heure on a que c'était
la question du Président vous nous avez
dit que
c'était très transparent puisqu'on
pouvait télécharger les données et qu'on
pouvait décocher le fait de
collecter les données je disais il y a
la théorie et la pratique parce que en
théorie il n'y a pas de problème
en pratique
j'allais dire personne ne le fait c'est
à peu près quasi personne en tout cas
dans mon dans
mon esprit
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quel
pourcentage parce que les enfants et
même les adultes d'ailleurs voilà ne le
font pas
donc la théorie est bien mais en
pratique est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire le pourcentage de personnes sur les
utilisateurs le pourcentage
d'utilisateurs qui télécharge les
données collectées sur eux et le
pourcentage d'utilisateurs qui décoche
pour voir si la pratique correspond avec
la théorie j'ai pas ces informations là
aujourd'hui mais je peux demander si
effectivement on peut vous les on peut
vous les fournir
ce qui est important c'est que c'est ce
que je vous disais un petit peu enfin
tout à l'heure c'est on est dans un
enjeu de communication et de faire
savoir aujourd'hui et c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on investit en média sur le sujet
je sais pas si vous avez vu passer les
campagnes mais depuis octobre dernier on
investit quand même très massivement sur
ce sujet et au sein de l'application et
en dehors de application donc au sein de
l'application à travers des campagnes
qui avec des créateurs qui qui
expliquent en fait ces fonctionnalités
et en dehors de l'application à travers
des campagnes sur de la presse
quotidienne
et magazine et en affichage etc donc en
fait on a un enjeu je vous rejoins sur
le fait de mieux faire savoir que toutes
ces fonctionnalités là existent parce
que parce que c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un outil important de contrôle
[Musique]
ce que je peux vous dire ce que je peux
vous dire en attendant c'est pour vous
donner un
un indice aussi de de l'importance en
fait des fonctionnalités qui sont mises
à disposition au sein de l'application
c'est que par exemple l'outil de gestion
du temps qui qui a été mise en place
c'est-à-dire les 60 minutes de temps de
consommation quotidien pour les moins de
18 ans avec ce message qui qui vous est
proposé au sein de l'application on vous
dit rentre en code si tu veux rester
plus de 60 minutes ce message là
aujourd'hui il est reçu par
trois quarts des moins de des moins de
18 ans c'est à dire qu'en fait à partir
du moment où on a mis en place cette
nouvelle fonctionnalité en avril 23 il y
en a entre guillemets que 25% qui ont
désactivé ce message donc ça veut dire
que on a un enjeu aussi nous d'éducation
parce que on se rend compte que quand
ces outils sont mis en place
ça envoie un message hyper intéressant
de oui tu dois savoir gérer ton temps et
on te met des outils à disposition pour
savoir le faire donc
on croit à la puissance de ces outils et
notre enjeu il est notre enjeu est
vraiment de mieux faire savoir et de
mieux les faire connaître
merci
[Musique]
parmi ces permissions
il y a la permission de récupérer
l'adresse MAC de l'appareil c'est-à-dire
le média access control qui identifie
l'appareil de façon unique
ça ne me paraît pas franchement
nécessaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
est la finalité de cette collecte ça me
paraît pas très nécessaire et ça me
paraît surtout très intrusif est-ce que
vous pouvez venir la finalité de cette
collecte alors je crois que c'est ce
qu'on appelle le device ID dans notre
jargon je pense que c'est c'est un outil
qui qui est un outil nécessaire pour
optimiser l'expérience de l'utilisateur
mais si vous voulez bien je reviendrai
vers vous précisément sur sur ce point
c'est c'est aussi un outil important
pour nos ciblages de campagne
publicitaires
parce que c'est compliqué de cibler sans
censé donner là mais je préfère qu'on
revienne précisément vers vous là dessus
il y a une autre collecte qui me paraît
posé problème c'est l'accès aux
presse-papiers
dans le presse-papier quand vous faites
un copier-coller
les transit par le presse-papier
beaucoup d'utilisateurs énormément
d'utilisateurs
pour ne pas répéter leur mot de passe
font du copier-coller et par conséquent
leur code leur code d'accès leur login
passeword
sont pas obligatoirement tout le temps
mais sont très régulièrement dans le
presse-papier d'autant plus que vous
l'interrogez en permanence je veux dire
votre application interroge en
permanence le presse-papier et d'autres
fonctionnalités de l'utilisateur
c'est quand même ennuyeux d'avoir par ce
biais accès
au code d'un certain nombre
d'utilisateurs qui se servent du
presse-papier pour passer d'une
application à l'autre parce qu'ils ont
le même code
alors quelle est la finalité de
l'utilisation du presse-papier et ce que
vous pensez qu'elle est vraiment
indispensable
on reviendra vers vous sur ce point je
ne saurais pas vous répondre
vous avez l'accès permanent au
calendrier pour le lire et ce qui m'a
paru beaucoup plus
interrogeant et le modifier est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire la nature des
données du calendrier qui sont utilisées
et la finalité de leur collecte
[Musique]
je suis très embêtée pour vous répondre
parce que je ne vois absolument pas le
lien entre l'application Tik Tok et un
calendrier c'est à dire que c'est
et donc je voudrais juste m'assurer que
cette information est juste parce que ça
ne correspond pas aux usages de la
plateforme donc je
permettais moi de vérifier que nos
collègues sur sur ce sujet
alors
je voulais vous parler des pixels
dans votre politique de confidentialité
vous dites nous et nos partenaires
utilisons des témoins pour pouvoir la
plateforme sur d'autres plateformes et
site web les témoins permettent à la
plateforme de fournir certaines
caractéristiques et fonctionnalités
jusqu'à présent personne ne peut
comprendre ce que ça veut dire par le je
peux vous répéter la phrase je pense
qu'une utilisateur à qui on dit les
témoins permettent à la plateforme de
fournir certaines caractéristiques et
fonctionnalités c'est la pure langue de
bois
mais plus loin vous dites les balises
pixels peuvent reconnaître les témoins
c'est plus loin c'est pas c'est pareil
donc il faut déjà faire le lien entre
les deux les balises pixels peuvent
reconnaître et puis il faut aller sur la
politique du confidentialité est-ce que
vous avez vos la même question que tout
à l'heure
le pourcentage des utilisateurs qui vont
sur la page politique de confidentialité
alors ça non je peux pas vous dire
effectivement parce que on peut aussi
aller sur la page confidentialité sans
être logé donc en fait faire le lien
entre un utilisateur Tik Tok et
quelqu'un qui va on peut pas matcher ces
deux informations ces deux informations
différentes par contre ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que le sujet du pixel
c'est un sujet publicitaire et qui
correspond effectivement à c'est une
pratique assez courante dans la
publicité qui permet de d'analyser
l'efficacité des campagnes et la
capacité à convertir donc ça c'est un
outil important pour les marques quand
elles achètent des campagnes
publicitaires
alors je vous allez me remercier je vais
vous signaler un problème
j'ai téléchargé ça il y a quelques jours
donc je pense que ça a pas dû changer
sur la politique sur la page de la
politique de confidentialité vous avez
un dernier paragraphe qui concerne les
conditions supplémentaires spécifiques à
la juridiction et ça fait un peu
ennuyeux parce que ça concerne pas la
France mais ça concerne le Canada donc
vous avez les les
recommandations et les informations pour
les utilisateurs du Canada donc je pense
que quand vous rentrerez Tik Tok vous
voyez leur dire qu'il faut peut-être
mettre ça à jour je suis étonné que
personne ne l'aurait fait remarquer
parce que ça a l'air d'être là depuis
longtemps
je par exemple
c'est une version québécoise
c'est la version québécoise
québécoise c'est celle qui est sur sur
mon ordinateur en France quoi on va
vérifier monsieur
et à mon avis c'est Tik Tok
c'est une d'ailleurs c'est une page
légale qui a l'air assez globale mais
enfin bref en tout cas je l'ai pas
téléchargé du Canada donc je pense que
tous les utilisateurs français auront le
même les mêmes résultats que moi vous
avez la possibilité que sur le sur les
sites en fait de mettre
de mettre différentes
URL et donc d'accéder aussi aux
politiques de confidentialité de de
UK ou d'autres mais bien sûr on
vérifiera et on s'assurera d'apporter
les corrections s'il y a une erreur a
été faite
dans cette politique de confidentialité
qui concerne le Canada mais je suppose
que l'article que l'article vaut pour la
France
il est marqué transfert à l'extérieur de
votre juridiction nous et nos
fournisseurs de services y compris les
membres filiales ou entreprises
affiliées de notre groupe d'entreprise
pouvant accéder stocker et traiter
autrement les renseignements personnels
à l'extérieur du Canada
y compris aux États-Unis en Malaisie à
Singapour et dans d'autres juridictions
étrangères ou nous ou nos fournisseurs
de services sommes situés
quels sont les autres juridictions
étrangères est-ce qu'elle comprenne la
Chine
notamment parce que c'est en Chine que
dans votre groupe d'entreprise
c'est-à-dire les filiales de bail
d'inskaïmans il y a le plus de il y a le
plus de filiales et d'entreprises alors
les données sont stockées les données
personnelles sont stockées aux
États-Unis à Singapour et en Malaisie
donc ça c'est vraiment l'ensemble des
données sont stockées sur ces trois
zones là et ensuite
le je crois que monsieur garandour m'a
parlé un petit peu ce matin on a je sais
pas si ça va répondre à votre question
mais on a des des
employés à travers le monde qui sont
amenés à accéder à certaines données
pour des raisons précises parce que ça
correspond à leur travail et qui selon
des protocoles très sécurisés avec de la
PSE udonomisation de données avec du
cryptage de données accepte accède à ces
données pour leur travail mais en tout
cas les données sont stockées dans ces
trois dans ces trois centres de données
et bientôt à horizon fin 2024 en Europe
pour les données personnelles en Europe
et donc il y a deux concepts il y a le
stockage et puis à l'accès
Tik Tok a déclaré il y a quelques à
déclarer à la CNIL à l'époque que il y
avait une dizaine d'entités chinoises
qui avait accès qui n'est pas de stocker
mais qui avait accès aux données
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas alors
je vois pas quelles sont cité chinoises
de quelles entité chinoises on peut
parler en l'occurrence
Tik Tok opère de façon autonome comme
une entreprise autonome donc avec des
équipes dédiées dans certains pays avec
un
sillo à Singapour avec une si haut basée
à Los Angeles avec des équipes
régionales en ce qui nous concerne à
Londres donc
la collaboration se fait sur tous les
pays du monde on est présent je crois
qu'il y en a 120 avec des employés à
travers le monde qui
occupent des responsabilités très très
diverses de du marketing au social aux
ressources humaines aux finances aux
produits voilà donc on est on opère
comme une entreprise internationale
assez basiquement
pour être plus précis je pense que je
crois même que TikTok
le reconnaît il y a des ingénieurs
chinois en Chine qui travaillent sur
l'algorithme de Tik Tok et qui échange
des données transférées
écoutez je crois qu'on a des
collaborateurs dans tous les pays du
monde la Chine en fait évidemment partie
après on est pas vraiment dans une
logique de savoir enfin moi à titre
personnel je travaille avec des avec des
employés de partout dans le monde et je
suis pas nécessairement
dans une démarche quotidienne de
regarder d'où il travaille ou est-ce
qu'ils habitent quel est leur quelle est
leur lieu de travail donc en fait c'est
c'est compliqué de répondre à votre
question parce que on a des
collaborateurs comme toutes les
entreprises internationales qui sont qui
sont qui sont basés un petit peu partout
dans le monde en fait et probablement
qu'on a des ingénieurs basés en Chine
oui sans doute
les
le site de Tik Tok
caïman ne dit pas tout à fait la même
chose que vous
ils disent certaines entités je traduis
certaines entités de notre groupe situé
dans des pays sans possibilités de
décision adéquate sont nous leur
fournissons sous les clauses
contractuelles standards un accès
déplacé un accès de loin
l'information décrite dans working
formations
collectons-nous pour fournir
d'importantes fonctions ces entités sont
situées au Brésil en Chine en Malaisie
aux Philippines à Singapour et aux
États-Unis donc il y a bien des entités
en Chine avec laquelle vous travaillez
absolument c'est ce que je vous dis il y
a probablement des des salariés des
collaborateurs en Chine comme la plupart
des grandes entreprises internationales
ont des collaborateurs en Chine donc
aujourd'hui c'est close
contractuel standard en fait elles font
référence à au pays effectivement dans
le cas du rgpd le rgpd considère qu'un
certain nombre de pays sont conformes
aux pratiques opérées dans le cas de
l'Union européenne donc il nécessite pas
de d'accord supplémentaires les clauses
effectivement contractuelles sont
appliquées pour les pays que vous venez
de citer qui nécessitent un accord dans
le cas du rgpd donc en fait c'est des
clauses qui ont été développées pour
être en respect avec le rgpd et pour
permettre à ce que tous les employés de
Tik Tok dans le monde puissent faire
leur travail et opérer la plateforme
donc on a des responsabilités
effectivement
vis-à-vis de notre communauté à
s'assurer que cette communauté en fait
qui fait la force de Tik Tok vraiment
c'est c'est le fait que on a un milliard
d'utilisateurs et que ce milliard
d'utilisateurs partagent des contenus
partout dans le monde quand je suis fan
de sport je suis intéressée par non
seulement ce qui se passe en France mais
également parce qu'il se passe aux
États-Unis
en Amérique latine etc donc le le la
force en fait de TikTok c'est c'est
cette communauté internationale et pour
la faire opérer on a besoin d'avoir des
collaborateurs partout dans le monde
alors en ce qui concerne la Chine c'est
un peu particulier parce que
vous ne partagez pas
les utilisateurs la Chine Tik Tok est
interdit en Chine
et par conséquent je vois pas l'intérêt
je vois pas
en quoi le fait de travailler avec des
ingénieurs chinois ou alors vous
travaillez sur sur ou alors ces
ingénieurs chinois ont taxé pour telle
ou telle raison à l'algorithme ce que
nous pensons d'ailleurs à l'algorithme
aussi bien de douille que de Tik Tok je
sais qui sont séparés mais ces deux
algorithmes celui n'est évidemment
traité en Chine celui de Tik Tok à notre
avis il est pour une bonne part
et donc je me permets de vous demander
quels sont ces employés et travailler
dans des entreprises
et des entreprises qui travaillent sur
des algorithmes c'est pas n'importe
quelle petite entreprise artisanales
dans la banlieue de Shanghai quelles
sont ces entreprises qui travaillent sur
l'algorithme de Tik Tok en Chine
j'ai pas de connaissances de
d'entreprises externes qui
travailleraient sur l'algorithme moi ma
compréhension c'est que effectivement
on uniquement des employés de Tik Tok
travail sur sur ce produit là donc
aujourd'hui on est enfin j'ai du mal
avec l'idée qu'on puisse effectivement
mettre en cause un collaborateur par son
origine ou par son pays en fait
aujourd'hui on a le le
en fait des équipes qui sont les
meilleurs parmi les meilleurs quel que
soit leur pays de naissance quel que
soit leur formation et ça c'est notre
enjeu principal et effectivement vous
avez beaucoup de boîtes de technologie
de ce pardon d'entreprises de
technologie qui qui ont des
collaborateurs en Chine parce
qu'effectivement il y a aussi un vrai
talent comme en France on a des
mathématiciens formidables et et voilà
donc je trouve pas ça personnellement
choquant d'avoir des des ingénieurs
d'origine chinoise dans l'entreprise
mais je sais pas peut-être que je
comprends pas votre question en fait
alors je voudrais pas que vous pensiez
que ma question faisait l'objet d'un
racisme anti-chinois et du fait que
c'est parce que ce serait des Chinois ça
ne me satisfait pas le problème et vous
le connaissez bien
et vous avez suivi l'audition de ce
matin visiblement
le problème c'est pas qu'ils sont
chinois le problème c'est que la loi
chinoise depuis 2017 et 2019 impose à
toute citoyen chinoise à tout ingénieur
chinois à toute société chinoise de
d'obéir de de renseigner les services de
renseignement chinois à toute demande et
par conséquent il y a aucune
confidentialité non seulement en soi
mais vis-à-vis du Parti communiste
chinois de la part d'employés en Chine
et je sais pas si les autres plateformes
travaillent avec des ingénieurs chinois
en Chine mais si c'est le cas et qu'il
transfère des données et bien ils sont
dans cette situation là que moi je
trouve absolument anormal et qui ne
correspond pas aux règles du rgpd
d'autre part quand on règle du rgpd vous
l'avez dit vous-même et en Europe ça ne
pose pas de problème par contre dans un
certain nombre de pays il n'est pas
d'adéquation par exemple aux États-Unis
avec le Cloud c'est pas compatible avec
leur GPD la loi chinoise n'est pas
compatible avec leur GPD elle nécessite
théoriquement un chiffrement
absolu depuis l'origine jusqu'à
l'arrivée aujourd'hui Tik Tok ne perd
pas ce chiffre romain ce chiffrement sur
l'ensemble du parcours des transferts de
données donc ceci oui il me pose
problème pas parce que ces gens-là sont
chinois mais parce qu'ils sont soumis à
la loi chinoise et que par conséquent ça
donne la possibilité de n'importe quelle
porte dérobée ce qui est important en
fait de juste peut-être de resituer
c'est que la façon dont on opère chez
Tik Tok c'est avec un principe de
gouvernance où les grandes décisions
sont prises par show qui est basé à
Singapour et par Vanessa papas qui est
basé à Los Angeles donc en termes en
termes de mode opératoire de stratégie
marketing commercial contenu etc
toutes ces décisions sont prises
finalement d'une façon très similaire à
n'importe quel organisation
internationale ensuite la compliance
rgdp fait rgpd pardon fait que en fait
on a la nécessité de nos assurer que
les stockages de données sont faits dans
des pays qui sont conformes à ce que le
rgpd nous demande et ensuite que les
personnes qui ont accès à des données
puissent le faire avec un niveau de
sécurité maximum donc c'est pour ça que
je vous parlais de de données cryptées
de donner de pseudonisation des données
etc donc c'est important de se dire
aussi que derrière de la donnée il peut
y avoir de la donnée anonymisée et c'est
bien entendu ce qui se passe c'est à
dire que on n'est pas dans la gestion de
données personnelles individuelles c'est
à dire que un ingénieur
noir en l'occurrence le seul exemple que
j'ai eu jusqu'ici c'est quelqu'un qui va
intervenir sur un bug sur un compte qui
n'affiche plus de vues et on a besoin de
déboguer ce compte mais ce que ça lui
donne comme information c'est des
données anonymnisées qui permettent de
régler le problème technique sur le
compte donc on n'est pas dans l'adresse
email on n'est pas dans du téléphone
numéro de téléphone on n'est pas dans la
donnée entre enfin voilà sensible quoi
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi et puis
c'est vrai que derrière donner on y met
beaucoup de choses une vidéo c'est une
donnée donc quand on veut régler un
problème sur une vidéo donc compteur ne
marche plus et n'affiche plus de vidéos
ça c'est de la donnée et donc oui
parfois on peut avoir besoin d'un
ingénieur qui a Singapour qui peut être
en Chine qui peut être à vrai dire j'en
sais rien c'est à dire que moi je veux
juste que le compte de mes partenaires
fonctionne donc c'est je pense qu'il y a
juste un sujet de quel de quelle donnée
on parle en fait
je suis d'accord avec vous et pour moi
il y a un sujet de
quand on vous écoute
c'est très très policé c'est très très
surveillé et on a l'impression qu'à une
petite partie qu'il faut vraiment
beaucoup d'autorisation et qu'il y a pas
une grosse partie des données qui part
en Chine nous ce qu'on nous avait ce
qu'on nous a dit jusqu'à présent un
certain nombre d'experts nous disent que
l'algorithme les principales fonctions
de l'algorithme ce sont
comment dire exploiter gérer améliorer
etc en Chine je ne sais pas chez qui
mais en Chine
et ceci suppose évidemment un flux de
données extrêmement important c'est pas
des petites autorisations par ci par là
alors est-ce que vous nous confirmez que
une partie importante je dirais pas
essentielle mais importante de du
fonctionnement de la gestion et de
l'amélioration de l'algorithme qui
nécessitent évidemment d'avoir accès à
énormément et peut-être même à toutes
les données se font en Chine aujourd'hui
je suis incapable de vous répondre à ces
questions on va les personnes qui
travaillent sur le produit et
l'algorithme auquel je parle sont aux
États-Unis à Singapour donc en fait je
non malheureusement je peux pas vous
dire ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de
voilà je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
s'expriment sur ce sujet qui ont pas
forcément le la matière malheureusement
et et en tout cas c'est pas la réalité
de ce que je ressens au quotidien moi
dans mon travail
si vous permettez monsieur le rapporteur
je crois que la meilleure façon de faire
en sorte que des gens qui ne sont pas au
fait de s'expriment pas à tort et à
travers c'est que des gens s'expriment
par ailleurs
et donc les personnes à qui nous avons
sous garant comme vous-même avez eu
l'obligeance littérale du terme de venir
devant la commission par définition mais
les gens qui n'y sont pas obligés
c'est comme le comme le fait de valider
ou pas le fait de donner certaines
données on n'est pas obligé de les
donner mais on peut le faire quand même
c'est pareil s'il souhaitait venir
s'exprimer devant la commission quand
même ils n'ont pas l'obligation de le
faire nous sommes tout à fait ouvert à
des entretiens par visio donc je crois
que le mieux si vous voulez éviter que
d'autres parlent pour vous si vous
estimez qu'il parle à tort et à travers
c'est que les sachants puissent nous
dire les choses qui s'occupent de
l'algorithme il y a bien quelqu'un qui
le fait ce n'est pas suspicieux de notre
part que de le dire toutes les
plateformes en quelqu'un qui s'occupe de
leur algorithme qui s'occupe de
l'algorithme qui a la main là-dessus et
qui peut nous répondre et je pense que
ne pas nous répondre ce serait une façon
de répondre et donc de laisser parler
d'autres personnes à qui nous
accorderions un peu de crédit sur les
suspicions qu'ils peuvent avoir moi je
vous invite à
comment dire à faire passer à votre
supérieur à Singapour à Los Angeles et à
l'autre supérieure etc comme nous
l'expliquait monsieur Garandeau ce matin
le fait qu'à un moment si les gens qui
peuvent nous répondre peuvent être là on
est preneur
alors ce qui m'ennuie c'est que vous
m'avez entendu le dire ce matin si vous
avez regardé
c'est que la réalité ne semble pas
correspondre
l'aspect parcimonieux des transferts est
très surveillé les transferts de données
dont vous parlez
Tik Tok ce qu'on peut comprendre étant
les attaques dont elle a été l'objet aux
États-Unis notamment de la part du
président de l'ancien président
répète sans cesse c'est dans ces
éléments de langage à l'ensemble de ces
de ces salariés
ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il faut
répondre aux questions que répète sans
cesse que il empêche toute transfert ou
consultation des données personnelles de
ces utilisateurs vers la Chine jusqu'à
ce que BuzzFeed en 2022 relevait le
contenu de 80 enregistrements audio
issus de réunion interne à l'entreprise
où l'on s'aperçoit que des ingénieurs de
l'application ont eu accès depuis la
Chine à ces informations
que les enregistrements prouvé
l'existence d'un administrateur d'un
administrateur principal en Chine qui
avait entre guillemets accès à tout
entre guillemets toujours tout est vu en
Chine affirme un membre du trust and
safety department de Tik Tok etc etc
évidemment comme d'habitude Tic-Toc une
fois confronté à des preuves a fini par
reconnaître la vérité par ailleurs en
2021 Tik Tok a payé 92 millions de
dollars à la justice américaine en
raison de fuite vers la Chine de données
personnelles d'utilisateurs
donc
quand vous nous dites
conforme à rgpd le cryptage est
parfaitement régulier les autorisations
sont très très parcimonieuses et
surveillées
et que dans les
réunions dans les échanges entre
personnels de l'entreprise
un membre du stress and sefy département
dit tout est vu en Chine comprenez que
ça nous pose problème
je ne connais pas ce monsieur je ne
connais pas l'histoire donc je ne
pourrais pas me prononcer dessus après
je ce que je peux vous dire c'est ce
qu'on vous a confirmé
Erica Ando et moi-même en matière de
respect du rgpd c'est la réalité de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans notre dans
notre travail chez Tik Tok oui sauf que
vous avez deux
enquêtes de la difficile portant
spécifiquement sur les transferts de
données et dans le résultat va être
annoncé pendant l'été dit la difficile
celui sur les transferts de données
de mineur et un deuxième je me rappelle
plus turquoise qui ce qui on va voir le
résultat mais qui selon la difficile
très visiblement ne correspondent
satisfont pas aux règles du rgpd
c'est un projet de décision sur lequel
je n'ai pas plus d'informations c'est je
sais que nos équipes travaillent main
dans la main avec l'aide difficile sur
ce sur ce sur ce sujet évidemment le
l'esprit de collaboration de coopération
et transparence s'applique dans le cadre
de cette enquête
je reviens ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
les pixels donc j'ai déjà expliqué que
le texte initial était très très vague
mais plus loin vous dites les blagues
display peuvent reconnaître les témoins
enfin votre document politique de
confidentialité les documents les bases
pixels peuvent reconnaître les témoins
leur et la date à laquelle j'ai consulté
une description de la page où la balise
pixel est placée et des renseignements
similaires provenant de votre ordinateur
ou votre appareil
comme d'habitude
[Musique]
ces vagues puisqu'on dit leur et la date
à laquelle une page est consultée une
description de la page de la balisée
très bien et des renseignements
similaires et à chaque fois dans les
phrases de la politique du constructeur
on a une description d'un ou deux sujets
et le reste et le reste n'est pas
détaillé donc je vous demande quels sont
ces renseignements similaires qui sont
sur les pixels que vous placez sur des
milliers de sites
en fait le pixel c'est un outil
publicitaire qui permet aux annonceurs
de mesurer l'efficacité de leur campagne
donc c'est c'est pas complètement
spécifique à Tik Tok c'est c'est
pratique courantes sur le marché
publicitaire et ça nous permet
effectivement de faire un meilleur
travail avec les annonceurs et de leur
donner des résultats de campagne
en matière de visibilité en matière de
transformation et d'efficacité de
d'investissement
aujourd'hui
la façon dont on travaille
chez Tik Tok la façon dont on a à coeur
de grossir faire grossir notre
écosystème c'est en encourageant
toujours une meilleure création de
contenu en travaillant avec les
partenaires les créateurs les
personnalités publiques pour qu'il
travaille pour qu'il développe le
meilleur contenu possible puisque le
l'efficacité de la plateforme vient de
la qualité de ses contenus et de ce qui
s'y trouve et c'est ce qui fait que les
gens restent et que les gens ont envie
effectivement de venir passer un bon
moment sur la plateforme donc le sujet
du pixel sur un site web on est vraiment
dans un sujet business B2B qui est un
sujet de campagne publicitaire mais
c'est pas quelque chose qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de d'améliorer l'expérience
sur la plateforme
alors je sais j'ai bien compris ce que
c'était des balises pixels mais vous ne
répondez pas à ma question qui est quel
renseignement similaire provenant de
l'ordinateur ou du téléphone sont
recueillis par les pixels en dehors des
trois exemples de nez quels sont les
autres on reviendra vers vous
précisément sur ces points
le site consumer report aux États-Unis
à
recensé plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de sites qui est sur lequel sont ces
pixels pour Tik Tok
en ce qui concerne les sites commerciaux
bon c'est un problème publicitaire vous
l'avez expliqué mais le problème c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres sites
qui utilisent ces pixels
qui place des pixels sur leurs écrans
si vous allez sur le site de l'église
Méthodiste Unie TikTok le C si vous les
métadonnées sont parfois autant de ne
pas autant de renseignements que les
données
si vous allez sur le site des Weight
Watchers ou sur le site du planning
familial ils sont en pixel pour TikTok
le site médical webmdi assez pixels si
vous allez sur la page 10 fonctions
érectile TikTok le C sur le site si vous
allez sur la page plan B contraceptif
d'urgence Tic-Toc le C
si vous avez si vous allez sur le Site
Recovery center of America qui gère des
centres de désintoxication Tik Tok le C
alors ça c'est les États-Unis mais
question sont les suivantes pour la
France est-ce que ces méthodes sont
utilisées en France est-ce que des sites
de cette nature fournissent des pixels à
tétées à Tic-Toc et
est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec le texte
qui figure sur votre page politique de
confidentialité que j'ai lu tout à
l'heure les utilisateurs de Tik Tok
peuvent comprendre de quoi il s'agit
alors le pixel pour moi mais on
reviendra vers vous précisément reste un
outil publicitaire donc ça veut dire que
ça part d'une démarche d'en annonceur
d'une marque de placer le pixel en vue
de mesurer une efficacité
publicitaire c'est à dire que Tik Tok ne
peut pas placer autoritairement un pixel
sur un site qui n'est pas le sien donc
il y a quand même une démarche du site
en question pour pour placer ce fameux
fixe ce fameux pixel dans un objectif
qui est probablement un objectif
publicitaire
c'est c'est
tout ça évidemment conforme au respect
des lois en vigueur au respect du rgpd
et au respect de notre politique de
confidentialité donc je sais pas je sais
pas à quoi vous dire de plus et
si ce n'est que c'est dans le cadre de
d'accord commerciaux et publicitaires
que cette ce pixel est placé
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire combien
de temps vous conservez les
renseignements
[Musique]
apportés par les pixels alors tout ça
est très réglementé dans le cas du rgpd
donc on est complètement dans le respect
du rgpd
il y a six mois en décembre 2022 Tik Tok
a été condamné par CNIL à une amende de
5 millions d'euros vous savez pourquoi
cette feuille a été supprimée depuis sur
le site internet
mais des journalistes aujourd'hui que
des tests informels ont permis de
constater qu'il était toujours plus
difficile plus difficile de refuser que
d'accepter sur l'application mobile
est-ce que ce problème est aujourd'hui
résolu écoutez dans le cadre de la CNIL
le l'amende qui effectivement enfin
portait sur un défaut d'explication de
d'un cookie et d'une difficulté à
refuser un cookie si ma mémoire est
bonne on parle d'une période de je crois
que c'était en 2018 une période
2018-2020 donc c'était on était vraiment
au début de de l'histoire de Tik Tok et
on parle aussi de de
cookies qui sont placés sur tiktok.com
l'usage de Tik Tok n'est vraiment pas
sur le web on est vraiment sur une
application mobile ou la consommation de
Tik Tok se fait sur l'application et pas
sur le site
donc sans vouloir minimiser le problème
bien sûr qu'il a été résolu et que le la
correction a été apportée sur tiktok.com
si tu as des questions ce gâteau là
probablement des questions sur un sujet
oui en soi bonjour madame si le
président ne rapporte tant mieux
autorise ça sera des questions courtes
mais un peu successives pour des
éléments je crois factuels moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup au monde de
l'entreprise et c'est lié à mon passé
sans doute et au fonctionnement
économique donc c'est pas des questions
sur les données l'utilisation des
données c'est mieux connaître
l'entreprise Tik Tok donc dont on a du
mal d'ailleurs dans les données
publiques qu'on trouve à déterminer
parce que tantôt quand on nous parle
d'audience on nous parle souvent d'un
agrégat Tik Tok plus douille avec 2,6
milliards
d'utilisateurs réguliers avec une bonne
partie ou un milliardier je crois dans
600 000 qui viennent de Douilly donc
déjà on a du mal à chaque fois qu'on
recherche y compris sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les sites spécialisés on
sait jamais trop précisément de quoi on
parle une chose est sûre c'est que en
termes de audience vous êtes je crois en
début d'année vous étiez le quatrième
réseau social en termes d'utilisateurs
réguliers avec une croissance
exponentielle et
une
entreprise dont on nous dit avec des
chiffres relativement crédibles en
termes de chiffre d'affaires donc de
revenus mais qui serait passé de 350
millions de dollars américains en 2019 à
2,6 milliards en 2020 4,7 en 2021 et 9,4
milliards de 2 dollars en 2022 ce qui
est une croissance effectivement
importante et exponentielle mais au
regard des autres réseaux sociaux qui
restent bien en deçà c'est une phase de
progression mais au regard de votre
audience et de votre quatrième rang vous
êtes parfois loin derrière des réseaux
sociaux qui ont une moins forte audience
je veux bien comprendre qu'il y a un
phénomène de dynamique globale quand
j'essaie de comprendre alors déjà est-ce
que ces chiffres correspondent à la
réalité est-ce que le chiffre de
9,4 milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires en 2022 pour TikTok au niveau
international fait sens
je peux m'exprimer sur TikTok et SAS
mais malheureusement pas sur sur Tik Tok
dans le monde ce que je peux vous
directeur d'une filiale internationale
je connaissais quand même j'étais
capable de présenter mon groupe à
l'international c'est donc vous devez
avoir des données quelque part ou alors
si vous pouvez parler que de la filiale
avec un périmètre d'un petit peu réduit
c'est compliqué en terme de
communication alors c'est on est on est
une société privée donc
[Musique]
je pense qu'on peut peut-être vous
communiquer des chiffres mais pas en
session publique
mais en tout cas dans le cas de cette de
cette
audition je peux malheureusement pas
commenter ces chiffres ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que votre remarque est
juste sur le fait en tout cas que on est
aujourd'hui sur une phase entre
guillemets de enfin votre remarque sur
le la part de revenus publicitaires par
rapport à la taille de notre audience
j'ai parlé de revenus tout court parce
que quand on parle de revenus
publicitaires c'est encore une autre
affaire puisque les données analytiques
faites par les et là c'est l'agrégat qui
est donné par les déclarations
d'annonceurs au niveau international ou
par les centrales d'achat on estime les
recettes publicitaires de
Tik Tok à 4 milliards de dollars en 2022
c'est-à-dire moins de la moitié de son
chiffre d'affaires donc j'ai un peu du
mal à comprendre vous voyez
parce que ce que je peux vous dire en
tout cas c'est que on est encore dans
une phase de croissance
chez Tik Tok et que on a aussi la
volonté de préserver l'expérience
utilisateur et qu'on a des formats
publicitaires qui sont des formats
premium donc on a un format qui
s'appelle topview qui est quand vous
ouvrez l'application tous les
utilisateurs vont le voir et ensuite
vous avez des vidéos qu'on appelle
infeed qui vont venir s'intégrer dans le
flux de vidéo que vous allez que vous
allez voir dans la page pour toi et
volontairement on ne sature pas aussi
notre audience de format publicitaire
parce qu'on veut que l'expérience soit
la meilleure possible donc on est en
corde on cette phase de stratégie aussi
de de favoriser entre guillemets la
meilleure expérience utilisateur
possible ça c'est vraiment alors à
défaut d'avoir un agrégat sur le chiffre
d'affaires et les revenus publicitaires
si tu m'autorises pour ne pas qu'on y
revienne madame nous dit moi je peux
répondre que pour la France oui donc
faire ce que j'allais dire au
donnez-nous la réponse pour la France ou
la SAS alors est-ce que c'est aussi
Benelux compris et pays du Sud ou c'est
vraiment périmètre France là les
chiffres que vous pouvez nous donner en
fait sur la France ce qui est finalement
encore une fois assez assez courant
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait la filiale
française
a pour actionnaire principal tik Toky
donc ce qui veut dire qu'en fait comme
d'autres filiales en fait en Europe
notre actionnaire principal et tik Tokyo
qui est élabore
nos stratégies commerciales marketing
etc donc toutes les stratégies de
produits de prix ou stratégie marketing
ou de contenu soit élaborés par tik Toky
donc en fait la France opère comme un
prestataire de service pour tik Toky uke
donc ce qui veut dire qu'on est rémunéré
par tictok pour ce travail qui est
apporté donc en fait le chiffre qui
correspond à la valeur de ce qu'on crée
c'est quelque chose qui est c'est un
chiffre qui est public qui est déposé au
greffe du tribunal de qui était de quasi
30 millions en
21 et qui sera de l'ordre de 42 millions
en 22 donc ça ça correspond à la valeur
de de ce qu'on crée en fait nous à
l'échelle
vous me posez une colle
ouais je devrais savoir pardon on vous
dira
non il y a rien de secret bien sûr que
non mais c'est en fait j'ai le chiffre
qui était déposé aux grèves de Paris et
je
sais plus et c'est quoi l'Europe du Sud
l'Europe du Sud en l'occurrence moi je
gère pas en direct les revenus
publicitaires en fait moi mon travail je
travaille plutôt sur la publicité parce
que le périmètre France
ce qui paye à Benelux et ce qui paye à
Europe du Sud et quel est le périmètre
de l'Europe du Sud à moins que vous ayez
pris le périmètre
je me présente Europe du Sud pour pas
faire une ribambelle de pays
opérée de façon indépendante
l'Espagne est opéré de façon
indépendante donc en fait on a le même
principe d'organisation
et on a à titre uke ce qui est
effectivement l'actionnaire principal
des autres entités à ma connaissance
donc c'est Italie Espagne ouais on a
Italie Espagne en fait depuis on n'a pas
de bureau au Portugal on n'a pas de
bureau en Grèce
en tout cas on a quelques personnes qui
qui servent ces pays-là peut-être en
Grèce côté régie publicitaire mais en
tout cas dans mes équipes par exemple
pour servir le Portugal j'ai une
personne qui est basée à Madrid et qui
va opérer sur le Portugal depuis Madrid
je reprends moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
plus généralement comprendre le business
model d'une entreprise comme Tik Tok je
sais à peu près ce que business model
d'une entreprise du numérique celle
d'une plateforme souvent elle est
hybride avec des services numériques
mais aussi des services physiques je
sais que le taux de la profitabilité est
assez longue sur des plateformes comme
Amazon qui a mis quand même à peu près
10 à 15 ans à devenir rentable Hubert ne
l'est toujours pas sur les réseaux
sociaux la rentabilité beaucoup plus
rapide Facebook créer en 2004 et
rentable dès 2009
aujourd'hui quand je regarde les
recettes supposées alors il y en a
peut-être d'autres que je ne connais pas
en dehors de la publicité un certain
nombre de prestations quand j'évalue les
dépenses en masse salariale je me dis
Tic-Toc au niveau international est très
loin d'attendre la rentabilité quand on
retourne sur investissement quand vous
investissez 1,2 milliards pour créer un
centre de données
en Norvège après en avoir eu un autre
vous êtes dans des investissements
massifs je dis vous avez des
actionnaires formidables parce que
accepter de mettre alors l'entreprise et
brillante puisque elle a une progression
de son audience qui est faramineuse
enfin vous êtes quand même sur du très
très long terme pour ce qui est un pur
réseau social par ailleurs quand je
regarde à la différence de douiller en
Chine ou il y a un bouton d'achat qui
incorporé qui vous permet de faire du
commerce en direct donc de rentabiliser
vous n'avez pas cette logique là vous ne
vendez pas vos données personnelles à
l'extérieur comme certains font vous les
exploitez et ça fait la richesse de vos
algorithmes et de votre travail mais en
termes publicitaire et vous le dites
vous avez des formats courts vous les
passaturer votre public et des langues
donc vous ne pouvez pas non plus même en
faisant de la publicité ciblée saturé je
comprends pas comment on construit la
rentabilité et le retour sur
investissement avec un tel modèle alors
je sais qu'il y a des tests qui sont
effectués dans certains pays où on a des
tests sans musique comme l'Australie on
a des tests où on envisage peut-être du
commerce en ligne ou en tous les cas du
bouton
d'achat
vous fournissez par ailleurs des
prestations puisque en fait quand on
cherche business model et Tik Tok dans
toutes les langues on tombe sur la
littérature interne qui est comment on
aide le business model des du Small
Business c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
prescripteur
de rentabilité pour des petites
entreprises commerciales mais sur votre
entreprise elle-même il y a pratiquement
pas de littérature
je dirais académique ou universitaire
j'en ai trouvé très peu en tous les cas
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer puisque j'imagine qu'on vous
entrez dans une entreprise comme
celle-ci il y a plus d'un an qui paye
sans doute très bien mais on suscite
toujours de savoir où va l'entreprise
c'est quoi son objectif c'est quoi son
projet et quels sont ces ressources ces
investissements et son avenir alors
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus s'il vous plaît
merci pour votre question
alors oui alors je me suis posé ces
questions là bien sûr en rejoignant Tik
Tok après la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité rejoindre aussi le projet c'est
parce que j'avais le sentiment que
ce produit était complètement
visionnaire et effectivement on passait
effectivement de cette de ces périodes
du social graphe au Condens graff et
avec le cette vision de de rentrer par
le contenu et je trouve que ça c'est
c'est une vision extrêmement forte et je
serai étonnée qu'effectivement le la
tendance évolue
différemment et soit et soit et soit au
détriment du succès à venir encore de
Tik Tok et de sa croissance
on a communiqué un certain nombre de
chiffres dans le cas de du questionnaire
qui était envoyé notamment sur des
revenus autour de ce qu'on appelle le
live gifting le live gifting aujourd'hui
c'est pas quelque chose qui est opéré
par les équipes en France directement
c'est opéré par des équipes qui
travaillent sur le marché français des
Français mais en l'occurrence l'équipe
est basée à Berlin et en fait le
principe du live gifting c'est parce que
vous êtes séduit par un contenu vous
allez avoir vous allez offrir des
cadeaux digitaux donc je sais pas vous
avez quelqu'un qui est en train de
visiter vous qui en voyage dans la
savane africaine et qui vous fait vivre
un moment live incroyable vous allez
avoir envie lui offrir un cadeau digital
aujourd'hui c'est un modèle un business
model qui est émergent en Europe qui est
aujourd'hui très développé dans d'autres
pays du monde d'autres parties du monde
mais c'est aujourd'hui une part assez
substantielle aussi des revenus des
revenus de TiK ToK on l'a déclaré dans
le cas de du questionnaire donc je peux
vous le dire donc quand on parle de
chiffre d'affaires pur
on a 62 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires sur la partie
publicitaire pure et on a 103 millions
sur le live pour qui correspondent à des
revenus liés au marché français donc ce
qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la part du
live c'est même si c'est quelque chose
qui peut paraître contre-intuitif et de
se dire ah bah c'est pas finalement
quelque chose de très évident est-ce que
les Français ont vraiment la générosité
comme ça pour offrir des cadeaux oui
aujourd'hui c'est c'est quelque chose
qui c'est un modèle un modèle qui
fonctionne ou vous avez effectivement
des gens des créateurs qui généreusement
vont créer des contenus formidables qui
sont en voyage qui sont magiciens qui
ont un talent particulier et la
communauté va avoir envie de soutenir ce
talent ou ce moment de partage donc ça
c'est un axe de revenus qui est aussi un
revenu intéressant et qui est vraiment
un revenu complètement émergent c'est à
dire qu'il y a quelques années on était
vraiment complètement sur un revenu
publicitaire et maintenant on commence à
regarder ces nouveaux modèles
vous avez cité le e-commerce le
e-commerce et testé dans certaines dans
certaines parties du monde c'est testé
aux Etats-Unis c'était au UK la logique
voudrait qu'il y a un certain moment
effectivement on amplifie le déploiement
du e-commerce le e-commerce en tendant
plutôt sur ce qu'on a le service qu'on
peut apporter à des petites et moyennes
entreprises la volonté pas devenir
Amazon mais plutôt de devenir des
acteurs de soutien de ces ce qu'on
appelle les Smalls un minium business
vous êtes un apiculteur vous êtes vous
partagez vos contenus et tout ce que
vous faites autour de la récolte du miel
toute l'année et vous créez une
communauté on vous donne la possibilité
de vendre votre miel par exemple sur
l'application donc ça on espère que ça
arrivera aussi un jour en France parce
que c'est un service hyper intéressant à
apporter à ces assez créateur là donc en
fait il y a toute une panoplie aussi
c'est là où il faut être agile il faut
être ouvert à ce qui se passe
autour de nous parce que les modèles de
monétisation sont en train d'évoluer
très fortement et l'enjeu de
l'entreprise est d'être sur les bons
modèles aussi mais des modèles qui
fonctionnent parce qu'ils apportent une
valeur c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on
force pas les gens à donner des cadeaux
digitaux en fait il les donne parce que
ils sont séduits par le contenu et
qu'ils ont envie d'encourager ce
créateur et je pense que
on voit bien que dans la publicité
publicité traditionnelle et même ciblées
les capacités au-delà de l'extension de
votre audience sont relativement limités
parce que plus dans des programmes très
courts vous insérez de la publicité plus
vous avez un risque de baisse
d'attention et de perte de durée
d'écoute donc c'est que du fine tuning
comme on dit entre la proposition
publicitaire et la proposition
éditoriale ça c'est une chose alors moi
j'ignorais l'importance du live gifting
ça explique peut-être que entre ce que
est noté au niveau international en
termes de revenus publicitaire propre et
des évaluations de chiffre d'affaires ça
explique que effectivement la publicité
occuperait une part aussi faible pour
autant ce qui m'intéresse c'est comment
vous monétisez les conseils que vous me
donnez aux entreprises parce que par
ailleurs vous parlez de rémunérer de
rétribuer les créateurs de contenu qui
eux-mêmes parfois font de la publicité
pour certains produits mais visiblement
c'est à ces gens-là que la publicité va
pas nécessairement à vous donc enfin je
me demande des fois si votre société pas
une une société une œuvre de
bienfaisance parce que finalement vous
proposez de rémunérer les créateurs vous
proposer aux gens d'offrir des choses à
d'autres personnes j'essaie de
comprendre réellement la base du
business model ça c'est côté recette
côté
dépenses ce matin on nous a dit qu'il y
avait 40000 personnes qui travaillaient
je dirais à la médiation modération des
contenus dans le dans le trast and
setting 40 000 personnes dans le monde
ça fait beaucoup de gens vous embauchez
des ingénieurs enfin si je fais calcul
j'ai trouvé sur les sites américains que
au niveau tout ce qui concerne
trust and savent teas à peu près 60
65000 dollars américains par an de
rémunération il y a des charges si
j'utilise ces ingénieurs et le volume de
gens au moins à côté de 30000 personnes
dans le monde 70 000 que je fais une
équation sur combien on cherche un
salaire moyen dans le monde ça dépasse
le chiffre d'affaires donc c'est ça que
j'ai du mal appréhender je comprends que
vous êtes dans une logique
d'investissement mais le secteur très
particulier des réseaux sociaux d'abord
parce qu'il est extrêmement mobile parce
qu'on peut progresser très vite et on
peut être concurrencer vous avez des
mitos ou qu'on ou des anciens acteurs
qui concurrent votre modèle on peut les
citer
donc Instagram ou d'autres qui
s'approchent de plus en plus de votre
modèle comment vous pérenniser tout ça
quel est la logique et
marginalement combien de gens vous
employez dans le monde à défaut de
pouvoir me donner des chiffres précis
une certaine idée mais vous devez être
un très gros employeur contenu du niveau
technologique de la modération que vous
dites faire sur les réseaux ça pour nous
c'est une inconnue et plus c'est
inconnue plus même si ça fait partie
d'une stratégie d'entreprise émergentes
plus c'est inquiétant
sur le sujet peut-être une précision sur
les contenus publicitaires même si
effectivement aujourd'hui on s'assure
que
l'expérience utilisateur reste la
meilleure possible les marques ont très
bien compris que pour faire un succès
sur sur Tik Tok pour que la publicité
fonctionne elle doit respecter les codes
et la grammaire de la plateforme et donc
bien souvent vous allez avoir des
marques qui vont utiliser des créateurs
pour raconter leur message de marque
donc
la force des publicités sur Tik Tok
c'est qu'elles se finalement mélangent
aux histoires aussi qui sont qui sont
créés et on se rend bien compte que
effectivement vous êtes en acteur de la
beauté si vous faites une vidéo
classique où vous présentez votre
produit vous avez moins de chance que
votre vidéo fonctionne que si vous avez
une personne qui vont expliquer les
bénéfices donc il y a des codes et
aujourd'hui les marques s'approprient de
plus en plus les codes et la grammaire
de la plateforme pour pour être efficace
sur sur notre business model on n'est
pas complètement dans la philanthropie
et
quand je vous parle du live gifting il y
a un modèle de rémunération qui fait que
Tik Tok va quand même gagner sa vie sur
ce sur ce modèle là
notre modèle est pas de entre guillemets
sur le les fonds
pour les créateurs et au programme pour
les créateurs l'enjeu pour nous il est
dans une phase de croissance de nos
assurés qu'on a les meilleurs contenus
possibles les contenus les plus
qualitatifs possibles et l'enjeu du
programme pour la création c'est de
rémunérer des créateurs qui ont déjà une
certaine communauté qui ont plus de
10000 abonnés qui ont généré plus de
100000 vues sur les 30 derniers jours de
les rémunérer parce qu'ils vont faire
des contenus que l'on qualifie de long
mais ça c'est dans notre jargon qui des
contenus de plus d'une minute et parce
qu'un contenu qui fait plus d'une minute
en général il y a plus de storytelling
il est plus il est plus qualitatif il y
a une plus jolie histoire et donc on
encourage la
de contenu long parce que c'est ce qui
génère aussi
de l'engagement sur la plateforme et des
vues qualitatives donc ça c'est un
modèle qui est un modèle à un instant T
qui est important pour nous dans notre
phase de développement de la plateforme
pour nous assurer qu'effectivement les
créateurs puissent être tout à la
création c'est à dire que un créateur
qui a l'obsession de trouver des
partenariats de marque parce que sinon
il peut pas vivre de son travail on met
en difficulté et donc c'est vrai que on
a à cœur de soutenir les meilleures
créateurs sur la plateforme pour qu'ils
puissent qu'on puisse amorcer le début
d'histoire de d'une très belle histoire
avec eux
là récemment aux États-Unis vous
développez parce que vous n'avez pas
qu'un seul réseau social au niveau du
groupe bidens se développe à partir de
Tik Tok le réseau social lemonade qui
est finalement assez proche dans
l'esthétique qui vise pas tout à fait
les mêmes personnes mais il semblerait
que un certain nombre d'influenceurs ou
de créateurs de vidéos très influents de
TikTok soit amené sur les monnaies est
alors peut-être que c'est une entreprise
de substitution en cas d'interdiction
comme c'est le cas dans certains états
de Tik Tok aux États-Unis ou est-ce que
c'est une volonté de décliner plus
généralement ce type de nouveaux réseaux
sociaux et est-ce que vous envisagez de
le faire en Europe et en France
c'est-à-dire d'avoir une version les
monnaies en France parallèlement qui est
un peu plus ce style de vie si j'ai bien
compris un peu plus je dirais jeunes
adultes que très jeunes adultes
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus encore ça
participe de quelle stratégie marketing
je crois que vous êtes très bien
renseigné
je
malheureusement je n'ai pas de
visibilité sur les plans de déploiement
de lemonade donc je pourrai pas vous en
dire plus effectivement c'est une
application qui est
dans sur des sujets art de vivre et qui
n'est pas que sur la vidéo qui est
également sur la photo la vidéo le texte
donc qui est plus large et la promesse
et un peu différente de Tik Tok donc je
suis navrée j'ai pas eu de présentation
en interne de lemonay donc je peux pas
tellement vous en dire plus mais en tout
cas c'est un une autre proposition qui
qui est très intéressante
d'accord et peut-être si on m'y autorise
moi j'ai été ce matin
un peu abasourdi par le
les effectifs des gens chargés d'un
modération 40 000 personnes dans le
monde parce que j'avais des chiffres aux
États-Unis puisque
on parlait de 1400 modérateurs aux
États-Unis
ça fait l'objet d'ailleurs des
investigations du Congrès il y a eu le
départ de monsieur Éric Anne qui était
en charge de cette fonction là aux
États-Unis alors tout d'un coup je
trouve qu'on a 40 000 dans le monde ça
fait beaucoup de gens qui a une
modération bien sûr par intelligence
artificielle et je dirais automatiser
des contenus tant mieux et c'est
accompagné d'une modération humaine par
secteur linguistique on a cru comprendre
aux réponses qu'on a eu ce matin
qu'effectivement bien sûr les questions
l'usage de la langue s'arrête pas aux
frontières nationales il y a des pays
qui sont multilingues donc les
la modération francophones elle peut
émaner de
d'employés francophones d'autres pays
puisque il y a le Canada il y a toute
une partie de l'Afrique qui parle la
Belgique qui parle le français et puis
on a des Français de l'étranger donc
toute la question de cette adéquation de
la modération sur la base linguistique
peut poser question parce qu'évidemment
nous avons des diaspora nous avons des
règles concernant la sécurité ce qui est
dit ce qu'on a le droit de s'exprimer de
dire qu'est-ce qui est délictueux en
termes donc tout ça c'est quand même une
gestion
colossale en termes de modération
concrètement quand on nous parle de 600
personnes
modérateurs entre guillemets dans la
langue française ces gens-là
quel est le volume qui travaille depuis
la France vous avez une idée de tout ça
parce que au moins sur le périmètre
français si vous pouvez nous indiquer
quel est l'impact économique en termes
d'emploi de Tik Tok c'est un élément
généralement de valorisation y compris
auprès des pouvoirs publics et des
autorités politiques
les 40 000 personnes sont 40 000
personnes qui sont dédiées à la sécurité
donc c'est au-delà de la modération
c'est tous les enjeux de sécurité des
utilisateurs donc c'est c'est pas la
cybersécurité par contre c'est la
sécurité des contenus
contenu donc voilà c'est c'est
extrêmement vaste en termes de champ
d'application
donc nous pourrons ce qui nous concerne
nos équipes de modération sont basées à
Dublin donc on a d'ailleurs un centre de
transparence qui est accessible depuis
2023 et et on sera tout à fait disposé à
vous emmener aussi si vous le souhaitez
les rencontrer échanger avec eux sur nos
stratégies de modération et la façon
dont on travaille rien tel que de
d'échanger effectivement avec les
experts sur place et de voir les équipes
pour pour échanger avec eux
[Musique]
et
donc ces équipes effectivement sont sont
mobilisés et travaillent en fait avec
des outils qui sont
déjà des règles communautaires qui sont
hyper précises et qui sont mises à jour
régulièrement qui sont disponibles sur
l'application qui sont disponibles en
ligne et qui sont finalement le cadre
avec lequel on va opérer pour décider de
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ce contenu
est-ce que on le laisse sur la
plateforme et ce qu'on le supprime et ce
que on le supprime du fil de
recommandation pour toi donc c'est vrai
communautaire elles sont vraiment très
importantes on a ensuite des équipes de
modération aussi qui sont plus proches
de nous en l'occurrence en ce qui nous
concerne à Dublin parce que on a besoin
d'opérer il y a pas 40 000 personnes à
Dublin
travail de manière délocalisée j'imagine
en l'occurrence on est 5000
collaborateurs en Europe pour Tik Tok
donc
on a donc on a à Dublin je j'aurais du
mal à vous répondre précisément mais
j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir entre 1500
et 2000 personnes à Dublin mais le sujet
de la modération il est complexe parce
que un on a ses règles communautaire qui
sont la base de de du processus qui va
donner de l'information et à nos outils
et aux équipes pour modérer et ensuite
vous avez une lecture qui est plus une
lecture culturelle ou certains contenus
vont être acceptables dans certains pays
et pas acceptable dans d'autres donc
vous avez aussi
ce travail qui est fait pour s'assurer
que on est dans le respect de la logique
culturelle du pays en l'occurrence
en France on va être très sensible sur
un sujet de nudité par exemple et
peut-être qu'on sera moins
en Amérique du Sud par exemple je vous
dis ça un peu par hasard mais voilà
c'est important d'avoir ça aussi en
contexte et nos outils algorithmiques
ils sont ils sont très puissants pour
évidemment modérer tout ce qui est
visuel
il modère tout mais il modère aussi
évidemment des contenus de nudité ils
vont faire le travail sur le sujet de du
harcèlement par exemple qu'on est on est
sur sur un sujet qui implique de de la
langue là on a besoin effectivement de
de soutien en matière de modération
humain donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a aussi des modérateurs qui
l'ont qui modernes dans toutes les
langues et y compris le français où sont
localisés c'est
modérateurs ils sont en l'occurrence pas
en France mais vous en avez un peu
Amsterdam on a ouvert
une équipe trop sainsetti Amsterdam vous
en avez à Dublin vous en avez à Lisbonne
vous en avez dans pas mal de pays en
Europe qui travaillent justement sur sur
ces sujets
et peut-être une dernière question si on
m'autorise qui qui relève aux est une
entreprise fondée sur l'innovation
technologique et l'innovation aussi
marketing donc j'imagine que vous
protégez vos procédés donc la question
de la propriété intellectuelle et
technologique elle est importante dans
ce domaine quand on voit les combats qui
a eu entre Apple et Samsung jusqu'au
design et à la forme des écrans et la
taille des écrans ou finalement ça
terminé plus ou moins par un match nul
parce que chacun avait pris un peu à
l'autre comment vous protégez-vous en
Europe parce que le droit européen en la
matière est assez unificateur mais
depuis le brexit et comme vous êtes
largement implanté à Londres et à Dublin
Dublin qui est quand même dans l'Union
européenne
vous faites un système de de dépôt de
propriété intellectuelle partout dans le
monde au niveau européen plus au niveau
britannique quel est votre stratégie en
la matière puisque on le voit vous
copier vous créez quelque part aussi vos
MiTo marketing
ailleurs quelle est cette quelle
approche j'imagine que vous devez avoir
des services juridiques assez
considérables pour cela et combien de
brevets ou de licence déposez-vous
chaque année je serais bien incapable de
vous répondre précisément à cette
question je suis certaine que nos
équipes juridiques pourraient qui sont
très talentueuses pourraient bien
entendu y répondre on a une direction
juridique à Londres qui qui pilote toute
la stratégie juridique pour la région
donc je préfère qu'on revienne vers vous
en tout cas que les experts vous
reviennent vers vous sur ces sujets
si vous pouviez demander aux experts de
nous dire également qui possède la
propriété intellectuelle de l'algorithme
principale de Tik Tok
parce qu'on ne sait pas
je voudrais vous interroger
sur le heating
la pêche d'accueil du site dit que cette
application fonctionne de manière
équitable et ouverte
alors moi quand je lisabeth je me dis
que le petit gars qui dans sa chambre
pense qui va s'il est bon sur sa sur son
téléphone et sur sa caméra
arrivé à faire un million de pages vues
à armes égales avec tous les autres avec
n'importe qui
c'est pas tout à fait comme ça que ça se
passe
je reprends un article de Fort
de janvier dernier donc il y a peu de
temps
qui explique que pendant des années Tik
Tok a décrit je traduis donc excusez-moi
si c'est un peu flou des cris son sa
page
puissante pour toi comme
rangé par comme comment dire
ordonnée par un algorithme qui prédit
vos intérêts basés sur votre sur
l'utilisation vous faites de
l'application mais ce n'est pas le
l'histoire complète
d'après un certain nombre d'employés de
Tik Tok qui disent que c'est source
révèlent je pense que c'est pas
tellement une révélation mais bon qui
révèle que en plus de l'algorithme
les équipes de Tik Tok et de Bayern
[Musique]
distille secrètement choisissent des
vidéos spécifiques et surcharge augmente
leur distribution en utilisant une
pratique connue comme easing en français
c'est des pousseur mais je sais pas
comment on appelle ça la poussette ou
autre chose
et ses employés disent que TikTok
recourt souvent meeting pour courtiser
les influenceurs et les marques pour les
entraîner dans un partenariat en
augmentant le nombre de vues le nombre
de vues de leur vidéo
donc ceci sujet ce que le eating a
potentiellement bénéficié à un certain
nombre d'influenceurs et de marques ceux
avec qui Tik Tok cherche des relations
de business au détriment de ceux avec
lesquels dicloc n'a pas de relation de
ce type alors
je voulais vous demander trois questions
la première c'est que
ce eating correspondent après l'article
à des
manuels à des procédures qui sont
exposées dans des manuels aux États-Unis
ça s'appelle mine eating PlayBook
je suppose que vous avez le même en
France et ça nous intéresserait d'avoir
ce manuel les recommandations de ce
manuel la deuxième question c'est est-ce
que cette pratique est annoncée sur le
site et la troisième question c'est
comment on fait pour augmenter les pages
alors le principe sur Tik Tok c'est
quelle que soit finalement nos gestes
que l'on décide d'acheter de la
publicité ou autre le
[Musique]
point de départ c'est d'avoir un bon
contenu c'est à dire qu'un bon contenu
il a une chance de devenir viral si il
est bon s'il est authentique s'y
respecte les codes de la plateforme donc
ça c'est la base pour pour toutes les
marques pour tous les créateurs et c'est
vrai ce qui perturbe parfois certains
créateurs c'est que ils nous disent ah
bah oui mais moi j'ai beaucoup d'abonnés
et certaines de mes vidéos marchent pas
bah oui parce qu'en fait précisément en
fait c'est pas le nombre d'abonnés qui
va qui va indiquer à l'algorithme que
cette vidéo est intéressante ce qui va
indiquer que la vidéo est intéressante
c'est parce que petit à petit de plus en
plus de gens vont l'avoir cette vidéo et
vont la regarder longtemps on l'a
l'aimait on la partager et donc ça va
donner un indice que la vidéo est
intéressante
donc en fait nous notre stratégie au
quotidien c'est de mettre en avant en
fait de nous assurer que les bonnes
pratiques pour faire un succès sur Tik
Tok soit connu par toutes les marques
par tout le tout les créateurs parce que
finalement c'est ça le secret ultime
c'est de faire un bon contenu un mauvais
contenu n'a aucune chance de de
performer sur la plateforme
quel que soit les moyens que vous allez
y mettre
que vous décidiez de d'acheter de du
média pour le pousser ou qui soit mise
en avant dans nos newsletters donc ça
c'est vraiment le le la règle pour tous
et ça s'applique ça s'applique pour tous
ce qu'on fait en fait à l'échelle locale
c'est que quand on va être partenaire
d'un événement ou qu'on va soutenir un
programme
on va éditorialiser cet événement donc
par exemple
au moment du festival de Cannes quand on
est partenaire du Festival de Cannes on
identifie certains contenus qui nous
paraissent être les contenus les plus
intéressants parce qu'on voit qu'ils
sont qui
qui sont aussi aimées par la communauté
et on va les mettre en avant via un
petit logo qui s'appelle officiel et ce
logo officiel va indiquer quelque part
aussi aux utilisateurs que
cette ce contenu il est pertinent quand
vous allez chercher du contenu sur
Cannes 2023 et donc ça va leur donner ça
va ça va générer effectivement un peu
plus de vues et ça va ça va créer un
effet d'élan pour que cette vidéo est le
plus de succès possible qu'il est
pertinent et choisi par vous ça c'est
une ligne éditoriale ça n'a rien de
exactement mais exactement pertinent
mais que vous avez choisi de le mettre
en avant le Conseil exactement donc en
fait le fait de de mettre ce petit logo
officiel c'est parce que typiquement à
Cannes on s'est mis d'accord avec un
certain nombre de partenaires qui nous
paraissaient intéressant le Festival de
Cannes en premier lieu on avait brut on
avait Télérama on avait des créateurs
dont on avait la garantie qui au moment
de de cet événement ils allaient faire
des contenus de qualité pour vous
remettre dans le contexte en fait de
descendant et vous qui ce qui paye qui
en fait c'est c'est l'intérêt pour ces
médias et c'est partenaires c'est de
d'être plus visible sur la plateforme et
vous votre intérêt c'est d'avoir des
contenus de vous estimez qu'ils viennent
réhausser ou éliminer l'expérience
utilisateur exactement l'échange de
procédés exactement et pour vous donner
le contexte parce que on est quand même
pas très nombreux en France pour vous
redonner on a fait l'exercice en fait
parce qu'on trouvait ça intéressant de
voir combien de vidéos on avait mis en
avant sur les sept derniers mois on a
mis 2700 vidéos en avant il faut savoir
que il y a 2,5 millions de vidéos
postées chaque jour sur Tik Tok c'est
pour vous donner le le
poids réellement de ces de ces mises en
avant par rapport à la réalité de la
quantité de vidéos qui sont qui sont
postées
moi ce qui me paraît pertinent c'est pas
le nombre de vidéos c'est le nombre de
vues parce que si on promouvant ces 2700
vidéos vous arrivez à quelques centaines
de millions ou quelques millions de
pages vues alors que les deux,7 autres
millions c'est quelques vues par vidéo
ce qui compte c'est le nombre de vidéos
vues pas le nombre de vidéos promues
alors c'est on pourra vous faire
l'exercice mais là on sera sur une
vingtaine de zéros après la virgule
c'est à dire qu'en fait le 2700 vidéos
par rapport à la quantité de vidéo qui
sont produites sur la plateforme c'est
infinitésimal et en fait ça nous permet
juste d'avoir au moment d'une mise en
avant que ce soit le Festival du Livre
de Paris Cannes la Paris Games Week
que ce soit Roland-Garros c'est de nous
assurer que en utilisateur il va on
facilite son expérience parce qu'il va
avoir tout de suite les meilleurs
contenus qui vont émerger d'entrée et
c'est c'est très tactique et on parle de
six vidéos en général par opération
qui sont rafraîchies je crois une fois
par semaine mais on parle vraiment d'un
d'une quantité extrêmement faible et
puis le fait de l'afficher comme
officiel SA garantit pas le fait que la
vidéo va avoir un succès décuplé ça veut
dire juste que nous on apporte un avis
sur le fait que cette vidéo est
intéressante
ça veut dire que c'est
ce n'est pas péjoratif c'est comme comme
dans la presse quand on indique publié
reportage
oui pour faire le parallèle mais pour
pour creuser ce que vient de dire
monsieur le rapporteur
ce qui est intéressant de savoir c'est
si vous n'aviez pas poussé cette vidéo
est-ce qu'elle aurait fonctionné ça le
truc parce que c'est pas sur le moment
que vous y gagnez dans votre modèle
économique c'est le fait que d'améliorer
le contenu et le fait qu'en fait c'est
sur Tik Tok que se passe les les moments
importants de ce type d'événement
souvent mondiaux c'est par la suite que
donc ça réhausse ça comment dire sa
fidélise la monnaie ça réhausse de votre
point de vue la qualité de l'expérience
et c'est par la suite sur la question
des revenus publicitaires par ailleurs
pas forcément liées à l'événement que ça
vous rend comment dire encore plus
visible ou prescriptif c'est ça l'idée
oui l'idée en fait c'est de permettre
aux utilisateurs de nous enfin de
permettre aux utilisateurs qui sont
intéressés par ce sujet là de ne pas
manquer ce qu'on pensait être les six
meilleurs vidéos de l'événement voilà
c'est sur des dizaines de millions de
vidéos donc ça nous permet effectivement
de d'apporter un avis éditorial sur
certains contenus
et donc de oui nos assurés que les
meilleurs partenaires qui font leur
meilleur efforts en l'occurrence sur le
Roland-Garros France Télévisions Amazon
Prime vidéo sur Cannes on avait
effectivement les partenaires médias
également France Télévisions brut et
d'autres partenaires médias qui étaient
présents sur place qui font un travail
absolument formidable sur la plateforme
un travail de très grande qualité et
nous assurer que ces contenus là sont
aussi valorisés
est-ce que vous nous dire quelle est la
part des contenus sur Tik Tok qui ne
résulte pas à proprement parler d'une
création
mais qui est un extrait d'un contenu
déjà existant
par exemple des extraits d'émissions de
matchs sportifs etc il semble qu'il y en
ait beaucoup que ce soit d'ailleurs une
façon de contourner les la non
possibilité de les exclusivités de
certains matchs sportifs pour des
chaînes
donc quelle est la proportion du contenu
création et du contenu retransmission de
contenu déjà existants
évidemment
au-delà de la question ça pose des
problèmes de droits d'auteur
et je crois que vous avez pas mal de
le sujet de
la plateforme Tik Tok aujourd'hui
je vous le disais en fait fonctionne sur
un principe de création originale c'est
à dire qu'en fait ce qui fonctionne sur
la plateforme c'est l'authenticité des
contenus et c'est ce que font la plupart
des grandes marques des grandes
entreprises et des créateurs qui sont
sur la plateforme c'est du contenu
original si vous êtes sur du contenu
reproduit vous avez beaucoup moins de
chance de d'émerger donc en fait entre
guillemets l'intérêt est inexistant
nous notre travail c'est c'est
d'accompagner en fait tous les ayants
droits dans une meilleure valorisation
justement de leurs droits par exemple
quand canal+ diffuse diffuse le final le
H Champions League notre job c'est notre
rôle pardon c'est de nous assurer que
ils vont arriver à faire savoir au plus
grand nombre possible qui diffusent
cette finale et de créer l'événement
avant la diffusion de montrer des des
moments phares pendant et de faire vivre
l'expérience après donc on a des très
bonnes relations avec les diffuseurs
aujourd'hui parce que ils nous savent
très bien nous utiliser et c'est un
travail on a des équipes dédiées qui
travaillent justement avec les
diffuseurs pour accompagner ces efforts
et pour nous assurer que on arrive à
générer le plus d'audience possible sur
les chaînes sur les services de vidéos à
la demande au service de la SVOD etc
donc ça c'est un point hyper important
et on travaille extrêmement bien avec
eux
sur le sujet de de des droits d'auteur
on a des accords sur la musique depuis
longtemps déjà depuis 2021 je crois avec
la SACEM notamment
parce que la musique fait aussi partie
intégrante de de l'expérience Tik Tok
Tik Tok c'est ça se consomme
effectivement c'est une vidéo qui se
consomme avec le son on donc avec
beaucoup de musique
au sein de la plateforme la musique est
extrêmement importante et centrale donc
les accords avec les sociétés les
sociétés de gestion de droits sur la
musique ont été ont été signés très tôt
sur les autres sociétés d'auteurs
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
aujourd'hui on a amorcé des
conversations avec certains d'entre eux
la SACD bien sûr on fait partie en
l'occurrence je j'ai pu commencer les
discussions avec eux au mois d'avril
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire deux autres
rendez-vous à l'occasion du Festival de
Cannes nous avons fait les les suivis
pour leur présenter les équipes
techniques les équipes commerciales pour
nous assurer que ces négociations
avancerait rapidement donc aujourd'hui
on est dans des entre guillemets des
temps de passage assez normaux d'une
plateforme encore une fois on a été créé
il y a 5 ans quand vous regardez les
accords signés par d'autres plateformes
ça leur a pris un tout petit peu plus de
temps que 50 pour pour les mettre en
place on est sur des enjeux
technologiques c'est à dire que il
s'agit de rapprocher des répertoires
d'auteurs avec une plateforme ça
nécessite des développements
technologiques
ça nécessite des API dédiés ça nécessite
beaucoup de choses donc en fait c'est
pas c'est pas une discussion qui est
simple c'est une discussion qui
nécessite voilà des conversations qui
qui vont probablement prendre un peu de
temps pour se mettre d'accord sur quelle
est la part de ce contenu sur sur la
plateforme et donc bien sûr notre enjeu
est de respecter nos obligations dans le
cadre de l'article directive de
l'article 17
on ne cherche pas à si soustraire on
travaille d'arrache-pied pour pour être
en conformité
alors je suis désolé de vous
décevoir madame ou de contredire mais
c'est pas du tout du tout ce que nous
ont dit les sociétés en question ou les
syndicats en question
le syndicat les dirigeants de la Société
des Auteurs et Compositeurs dramatiques
sont extrêmement en colère en tout cas
il était devant nous
leur directeur général nous a fait la
déclaration suivante les discussions
avec les plateformes sont longues et
compliquées mais elles finissent par
aboutir ce n'est pas du tout le cas du
Tik Tok dans les méthodes aboutissent
aujourd'hui à bloquer toute discussion
par le biais d'action dilatoire par
exemple l'exigence de clause de
confidentialité inacceptable et
exorbitante un exemple l'interdiction
pour nous de référer de discussion au
conseil d'administration de la socd
évidemment si on peut pas référencer
d'administration on va pas on voit mal
comment on peut aboutir un accord
le résultat est que depuis que Tik Tok
est installé en France et vous dites que
c'était il y a 5 ans la société n'a pas
versé un centime à la Société des
Auteurs et Compositeurs dramatiques
le directeur général de la SSD qualifié
cette pratique devant nous de piraterie
audiovisuelle et il nous indiquait
qu'une plainte était en préparation
on a interrogé également les dirigeants
de la SACEM qui sont un peu moins
remontés mais quand même pas mal remonté
et ceux du Syndicat national de des
entreprises phonographiques alors eux
ils sont tout aussi remontés que la SACD
et ils nous disent que par rapport aux
autres plateformes les sommes versées
par Tik Tok sont infime
Olivier nus qui est PDG d'Universal
Music France déplore que Tik Tok ne
rémunère pas du tout à la hauteur
qu'elle devrait la musique utiliser et
Frédéric Delacroix délégué général de
l'association de lutte contre la
piraterie audiovisuelle relève de
sérieux problèmes au niveau des droits
d'auteur des oeuvres des fusées sur Tik
Tok
alors ma question pensez-vous qu'il soit
conforme à la déontologie de monter des
opérations de communication à grands
spectacle avec le fait si Val de Cannes
ou le festival du livre où les musées
nationaux sans avoir versé depuis que
vous existez un centime au titre des
sommes dûes aux auteurs et compositeurs
quand est-ce que vous comptez mener avec
la SACD des négociations sérieuses et
quand est-ce que vous pensez payer vos
dettes à ces différentes sociétés en
tout cas pour le moment depuis 5 ans
Tik Tok se conduit d'une façon qu'on
pourrait résumer on vit dans
l'illégalité pendant des années et on
voit après
alors ce que je peux vous dire déjà au
préalable c'est que nous avons aussi des
relations avec les ayants droits de ces
de ces
de ceux qui possèdent cette propriété
intellectuelle et vous avez la
possibilité de signaler du contenu qui
est votre propriété sur la plateforme ou
de remplir un formulaire pour faire
retirer du contenu qui vous appartient
donc aujourd'hui
ça c'est quelque chose c'est un modèle
qui fonctionne bien avec lequel on opère
donc vous avez un certain nombre de
d'auteurs et de propriétaire de
propriété intellectuelle qui nous
signale les contenus et nous retirons
les contenus qui sont de la reproduction
contenu donc ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point sur la SSD cette
audition a eu lieu avant des discussions
extrêmement courtoises et productive
avec la SSD que nous avons eu à Cannes
le
l'accord de confidentialité sur le point
d'être signé donc on est parfaitement en
phase et les premiers rendez-vous
techniques vont être calés très
prochainement donc sur la SSD pour moi
c'est réglé enfin c'est en cours en tout
cas on a mes premières discussions au
lieu en avril
avec la SACD
sur le sujet de encore une fois de la
société de gestion collective
la réalité est que on ne veut pas se
soustraire à nos obligations mais pour
définir un modèle de rémunération et les
autres plateformes sont passées par ces
modèles là donc vous le savez
probablement on a besoin de que nos
technologies se parlent c'est à dire que
entre les 50 000 les 60 000 œuvres
protégées par la SACD et la réalité de
leur présence sur notre plateforme il
faut être en capacité de le mesurer donc
ça ça prend du temps de développer ces
outils et c'est bien l'objet des
discussions qu'on a avec eux aujourd'hui
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ça a
pris très longtemps et des années pour
les autres plateformes également
sur la musique écoutez pour moi la
relation avec la SACEM est plutôt est
plutôt bonne donc je me permettrai de
creuser et de comprendre quels sont
leurs potentiel motivés
aux dernières informations tout allait
bien ils sont très actifs d'ailleurs sur
la plateforme ils créent du contenu très
intéressant et pour moi l'accord est
conforme à nos obligations quant aux
maisons de au label aux maisons disques
aujourd'hui on a une collaboration
extrêmement positive avec eux ils savent
à quel point Tik Tok je roule un roux
joue un rôle clé dans la carrière des
des artistes à quel point ils sont
capables de mesurer aujourd'hui le début
d'une popularité sur Tik Tok et la
conversion en termes de stream payant
ensuite aussi sur d'autres plateformes
donc le on a un écosystème vertueux sur
la musique et en tout cas
nos nos obligations en matière de
rémunération de de ces droits musicaux
sont bien sont bien en règle
[Musique]
nous dira qui est en bénéficient le plus
mais c'est un sujet difficile et dans
les accords que vous nous annoncez vous
comptez payer
les dettes des 5 années de retard des
cinq années qui viennent de se passer
écoutez je
les pour l'instant la négociation
commerciale a pas vraiment démarré et je
pense que c'est pas forcément dans le
cas d'une commission d'enquête que je
peux dévoiler l'objet de ces
négociations mais
j'imagine que
vous serez tenu parfaitement au courant
de l'évolution de ces discussions avec
les sociétés d'auteur et encore une fois
on est dans une démarche volontaire et
on ne cherche pas à se soustraire à ses
à ses obligations là
alors je voudrais que nous parlions de
l'addiction
ou de la dépendance ça dépend les gens
disent des choses différentes
je vous cite un article du Monde TikTok
rendrait-il accro alors que Facebook
Instagram ou Youtube était surtout
accusé d'enfermer les internautes dans
des bulles de filtres de propager de la
désinformation de polariser les opinions
l'application chinoise est accusée
d'abrutir la jeunesse Tik Tok et du fin
d'année numérique qui rend nos enfants
dépendants déclarait en novembre my
Gallagher un élu américain République
Bernstein Resort je parle de crack
numérique qui devrait livrerait des
l'endorphines à chaque swipe l'économie
s'olivier Barbot auteur de la tyrannie
divertissement décrit lui Tik Tok comme
un opium mental dans le Figaro je vous
passe les déclarations du président de
la République que vous que vous
connaissez sans doute
et je vous passe également les
déclarations
des associations familiales les agents
de parents qui nous expliquent le nombre
de plaintes qu'ils ont de d'adhérents ou
de non-adhérents leur disant que leurs
enfants passent leur nuit sur
l'application etc etc le
l'algorithme de Tik Tok est
particulièrement addictive vous le savez
ça pose des problèmes majeurs et les
nombreux psychologues que nous avons vu
à 80% certains pensent qu'il y a pas de
problème mais à 80% les nombreux
psychologues ou spécialistes que nous
avons vu sont extrêmement
critique c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il y a un vrai phénomène
d'addiction et de d'heures passées sur
le il y a d'autres phénomènes d'ailleurs
la dysmorphophobie la chirurgie
esthétique les filtres etc
c'est quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes alors en Chine on résout une
partie des problèmes en limitant le deal
la possibilité de visiter le site à 40
minutes et on le ferment de 22h à 6h du
matin vous vous avez trouvé une autre
solution c'est les 60 minutes au bout
desquels
on explique que vous êtes là déjà depuis
60 minutes mais voilà on vous donne un
code c'est à peu près comme si vous
mettez sur un paquet de cigarettes ne
prenez pas la prochaine cigarette
évidemment les enfants ça fait les
adolescents savent parfaitement
comment faire et j'aimerais d'ailleurs
savoir si vous avez mesuré l'efficacité
de cette méthode mais moi je n'y crois
pas une seconde
c'est vraiment un problème majeur je
pense que et dans le cas du SACD dans le
cadre du DSA vous allez avoir à régler
ce problème notamment par le contrôle de
l'âge et par un certain nombre d'autres
d'autres applications
franchement ça va pas du tout ça ça va
pas du tout cette partie de
l'application et ça va pas du tout pour
beaucoup de monde et je peux vous dire
que si vous entendez les déclarations
d'un certain nombre de psychologues qui
nous ont expliqué des cas etc bien
entendu ça concerne pas tout le monde
bien entendu ça concerne pas 100% des
adolescents ça concerne peut-être 5% des
adolescents ceux qui sont mais justement
ces 5% des adolescents qui ont des
problèmes psychiques au départ et qui
sont terriblement aggravés sérieusement
pas 100% mais c'est sur ceux qui sont
fragiles que ça pose un problème et ce
problème est loin d'être résolu chez
vous
le sujet il est important évidemment
enfin le sujet du bien-être et du
bien-être numérique évidemment est
important pour nous il est important
pour j'imagine toutes les plateformes
et c'est un sujet sur lequel on passe du
temps on réfléchit beaucoup à toutes les
solutions une des solutions en tout cas
sur lequel moi à mon niveau je peux agir
c'est de m'assurer que dans nos gestes à
l'échelle de la France on va s'assurer
de créer du contenu le plus qualitatif
possible pour que l'expérience sur la
plateforme soit entre guillemets la plus
génératrice de valeurs et quand on
travaille sur effectivement
promouvoir un événement autour du livre
promouvoir un événement autour du cinéma
promouvoir un des événements autour du
sport comment on le fait en ce moment
avec Roland Garros comme on le fera avec
le Tour de France comme on le fait avec
beaucoup d'autres événements sportifs on
s'assure en tout cas que la qualité des
contenus est à la hauteur
c'est c'est ça la réalité c'est pas la
qualité la qualité des contenus il y a
une petite partie c'est du pâté
d'alouette et de cheval il y a une
petite partie d'alouette et puis le
reste c'est du cheval le reste c'est de
la vidéo qui défile c'est de l'addiction
c'est des mômes qui dorment pas c'est
des troubles du développement cognitifs
ne dites pas que vous avez que vous
allez régler ça en augmentant la qualité
du contenu c'est pas une seconde
pourquoi ne prenez-vous pas l'exemple de
la Chine pour une fois et pourquoi ne
limitez vous pas comme le tabac est
interdit aux enfants l'alcool est
interdit en vente etc pourquoi ne
limitez vous pas c'est pas qu'elle se
serait pas une une nouveauté
l'utilisation de votre plateforme si ce
n'est pour des raisons
d'augmenter le nombre de utilisateurs
donc de compter les recettes
permettez-moi de
d'être en désaccord avec votre premier
point parce que c'est mon travail donc
en fait je pour moi c'est important en
fait de d'améliorer la qualité et de
continuer à soutenir des des moments
importants à l'échelle du pays et de
nous assurer que la qualité de des
contenus soit la plus importante
possible je pense que ça c'est c'est un
premier élément de réponse ensuite on a
beaucoup de fonctionnalités qui sont à
disposition au sein de la plateforme et
sur lequel j'en ai parlé un petit peu au
début sur lequel on doit faire un
meilleur travail de communication et le
mettre à disposition les 60 minutes
auxquelles vous faites référence pour
les moins de 18 ans Tik Tok est la seule
plateforme à avoir pris cette initiative
donc
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de félicitations
pour ça mais on trouve que quand même
c'est une super initiative et
aujourd'hui trois quarts des moins de 18
ans ont une fonctionnalité de gestion de
temps d'écran qui est activé sur leur
plateforme
ça veut dire que euh
[Musique]
ça vous empêche pas effectivement de
de continuer à vivre l'expérience sur la
plateforme mais en tout cas c'est un
message important qui vous fait
réfléchir sur quel est le temps que vous
êtes prêt à accorder à cette expérience
sur la plateforme donc la fonction les
fonctionnalités aujourd'hui
vous permet d'être en contrôle de ce
temps d'écran on a le mode connexion
famille sur lequel on veut aussi
continuer à plus communiquer parce qu'il
est extrêmement puissant il permet aux
parents de d'avoir des des
tableaux de bord chaque semaine sur le
temps d'écran de leurs enfants de
contrôler le temps d'écran par jour
c'est à dire que si vous voulez donner
plus de temps de mercredi que le mardi
vous pouvez le faire de vous assurer que
vos enfants communiquent uniquement avec
leurs amis etc donc il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'on peut faire par
l'intermédiaire des parents et on a
besoin de construire cette relation avec
les parents aussi pour qu'ils soient nos
meilleurs alliés donc les outils sont à
disposition sur la plateforme et on doit
effectivement s'assurer que
on en fasse un meilleur usage
vous nous dit tout à l'heure que les
pousses les poussées de contenu
représentent sont une goutte d'eau par
rapport à l'ensemble de l'utilisation et
là vous nous dites on est en train de
travailler sur l'amélioration des
contenus pour que les expériences soient
plus enrichissantes etc
c'est pas vous allez pas me convaincre
deuxièmement vous me parlez du contrôle
parental si vous mettez cette action sur
le contrôle parental c'est justement
parce qu'il y a des problèmes et moi ce
que je pense c'est que les applications
comme la vôtre elle devrait pas se fier
sur le contrôle parental pour m'aider
milliers de raisons mais pour une
notamment j'ai vous êtes certainement
beaucoup plus au fait que moi de ça
c'est que ça introduit une ségrégation
sociale évidente les parents au CSP plus
sont beaucoup plus contrôleur des
applications de leurs enfants à
commencer d'ailleurs par les par les
responsables des grandes plateformes qui
interdisent très souvent leurs enfants
carrément de d'utiliser des écrans mais
en tout cas les CSP+ sont infiniment
plus
vigilant que les CSP moins par
conséquent aux introduisez une
discrimination sociale en faisant ça
considérable ou la renforcez pour moi et
c'est pour ça que je vous demande par
exemple Nintendo le fait vous dites que
dans les seuls à le faire Nintendo le
fait d'une façon plus switch aussi sur
les 60 minutes donc il n'y aura pas une
protection by design de l'application
sur le temps d'utilisation ou sur
d'autres choses tout le reste excusez
moi mais ça n'est pas sérieux
le safety by design il commence par le
60 minutes par jour
sur pour tous les mois de 18 ans vous
avez pas d'autres plateformes
aujourd'hui qui qui le propose au bout
de 60 minutes en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que trois quarts des
moins de 18 ans conserve cette
fonctionnalité ne la désactive pas donc
c'est énorme c'est c'est significatif
non mais ce qui compte c'est le résultat
mais c'est là dessus je voulais vous
interroger techniquement
je pense vraiment que vous avez la
possibilité de savoir
combien s'arrête d'abord ne serait-ce
que d'un point de vue
de des questions de pouvoir faire valoir
à vos annonceurs comment fonctionne les
utilisateurs c'est fondamental pour vous
de savoir comment se comportent vos
consommateurs comme pour tout
entreprises et pas uniquement dans le
domaine de la technologie donc moi
j'aimerais savoir
s'il le faut vous pouvez nous le dire
par écrit après coup mais il y en a que
25% qui qui suppriment cette possibilité
d'être informé au bout de 60 minutes
mais combien s'arrête dans un dans le
quart d'heure mettons qui suit le
puisque les
neuropsychologues expliquent souvent que
c'est pas sur le moment même c'est parce
qu'on sait que ça va s'arrêter quand on
a un petit laps de temps supplémentaire
puis après on s'arrête comme quand on
dit tu vas arrêter la télé c'est jamais
sur le moment c'est rarement sur le
moment est-ce que vous avez la
possibilité technique oui ou non de nous
dire plus tard s'il le faut combien
s'arrête au bout des 60 minutes ou
presque il me semble important parce que
mettre les 60 minutes pour dire
vous savez il y a les dix commandements
depuis 2000 ans et pour autant il y a
toujours des gens qui tuent donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est de savoir ce que
ça produit derrière donc si vous avez
cette information techniquement nous
sommes preneurs
on reviendra vers vous effectivement si
nous reviendrons vers vous maintenant
puisque vous nous répondez sur ces
questions je voudrais les prendre
en entonnoir et puis pour pour essayer
de faire apparaître et me faire
comprendre de ceux qui suivent nos
travaux
si un enfant qu'on a dans son entourage
se met à s'enfermer dans sa chambre 12
heures par jour au bout d'un moment pour
relire tant qu'il est déjà lu tout
Proust puisque on dit toujours relire
Proust
est-ce qu'on laisse un gamin s'enfermer
dans sa chambre pour relire Proust 12
heures par jour tout un été
vous êtes pas psychologue l'initienne
mais ce qu'on peut admettre entre nous
qu'à un moment on propose d'aller
prendre l'air
je sais pas combien de temps on admet
qu'un gamin sans ferme et se mettre à
lire de la grande littérature mais il
arrive un moment où ça devient
acceptable
au regard de ce que nous font remonter
les psychologues cliniciens au regard
c'est du qualitatif et pas du
quantitatif ou pas de l'objectif est
statistique me regarde chacun dans nos
circonscriptions de ce que peuvent nous
raconter des enseignants ou des
personnes chargées des enfants chargées
d'encadrer des enfants dans les collèges
par exemple vous avez des familles et ça
revient souvent enfin en tout cas moi
c'est ma perception où vous avez des
familles qui lorsqu'elles sont invitées
à venir s'expliquer avec les enseignants
sur la difficulté du comportement d'un
enfant en classe ou d'un enfant qui va
pas bien les familles vous expliquent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas supprimer
l'application ils ne peuvent pas gérer
la réaction de l'enfant qui accepte
ingérable de supprimer alors on va dire
les réseaux sociaux seulement nous n'y
pouvons rien si celui qui est en pleine
expansion et qui est sur quasiment tous
les téléphones des lycéens et ou des
collégiens quand nous avons ici des
visites au Sénat ça nous arrive souvent
d'accueillir des scolaires
nos circonscriptions depuis trois mois
je pose la question systématiquement qui
n'a pas TikTok le gamin il ose même
celui qu'il n'a pas n'ose même pas lever
le doigt mais bon en gros tout le monde
a Tic-Toc mais rigueur tant mieux là
jusque là jusque là tout va bien
donc ma question c'est le 1h je
comprends mais à partir de combien de
temps vous pouvez admettre que ces
patenables et donc est-ce que 4 heures
par jour c'est tenable est-ce que 3
heures par jour c'est tenable qu'est-ce
qui ne vous donnerait pas le bourrôles
de dire ben nous on coupe au bout de
temps de temps
c'est 60 minutes ils sont issus de de
d'études c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on n'a
pas décidé on sait pas à réveiller un
matin en disant tiens 60 minutes ça
paraît tranche rond faisons ça en fait
il y a eu beaucoup d'études avec des
experts des médecins des psychiatres qui
ont fait cette recommandation
effectivement sur un 60 minutes par jour
ce qui se passe c'est c'est que quand le
mineur va passer cette étape des 60
minutes à 100 minutes il va recevoir une
nouvelle notification qui va lui dire
vraiment faudrait vraiment aller sur tes
outils de gestion du temps et commencer
à contrôler ton temps donc en fait on a
cette démarche proactive de renvoyer des
messages on a aussi un sujet de mise en
sourdine des notifications puisque les
notifications sont aussi une forme de
d'appel à aller consommer donc en fait
on met en sourdine pour les moins de 15
ans de 21h jusqu'à 8 heures je crois le
matin les notifications pour les est-ce
que c'est comment dire à ce que c'est en
série si je peux le dire comme ça c'est
pas en option c'est par défaut c'est
automatique et il ne voit pas en
sourdine pardon
il ne le voit pas apparaître sur l'écran
exactement et pour les 16 17 ans c'est
de 22h à 8h donc en fait on a aussi agi
sur ce cette notion de notification pour
que la notification soit par un appel à
venir à venir
se reconnecter sur le téléphone donc en
fait on a des gestes pour essayer de
renvoyer et de rappeler l'existence de
ces de ces outils je suis assez d'accord
avec vous sur le fait que on sera plus
fort si la démarche elle vient du mineur
que si elle est imposée par les parents
néanmoins les outils de gestion du temps
et le mode connexion famille il est
quand même très intuitif sur la
plateforme donc on a la conviction que
ça s'adresse pas simplement un CSP+
c'est que aujourd'hui jumeler pareil
c'est comme quand on jumelle un
téléphone avec sa voiture ou que
jumeler un deux appareils c'est quand
même pas complètement sorcier par contre
il faut que les gens le sachent et il
faut que les gens sachent que ce mode
connexion famille existe et donc c'est
aussi pour ça que nous on investit et
qu'on fait des campagnes marketing pour
ça au sein de l'application on a aussi
des campagnes avec des créateurs qui
vont faire la promotion de ces de ces
outils techniques de gestion du temps
donc ça c'est des choses dans le cas de
nos campagnes marketing où nous on va
investir on va acheter une prestation de
service et un créateur pour qu'il
explique effectivement que ces outils
existent après interdire
c'est compliqué d'avoir cette posture là
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est quand
même dans un pays de liberté
si la loi l'impose bien sûr qu'on se
conformera on se conformera à la loi
mais c'est compliqué en termes de
posture de dire Tik Tok va être accusé
de de censure chinoise
je sais pas quelle est notre posture je
sais pas comment vous répondre en fait à
cette question je sais pas si on peut
interdire réellement ou imposer en fait
on est dans un pour moi dans un rôle
d'éducation et d'accompagnement qui est
notre rôle le fait de d'interdire ou de
limiter de vous même décider de ne plus
émettre comme l'ORTF à l'époque à partir
de 23h personne pourra vous le reprocher
quelle serait la posture de Tik Tok
vis-à-vis des autres plateformes
pour terminer là-dessus simplement
regarder des éléments que vous pourriez
nous apporter par écrit je vous cite un
travail d'une journaliste qui a publié
un ouvrage comme vous le savez en mars
2023 sur Tik Tok nous avons à ce stade
très peu page 161 nous avons ce stade
très peu d'informations sur la matière
dans le gouvernement que représente Tik
Tok affecte les utilisateurs leur image
de même ou leur incapacité leur capacité
pardon de concentration pour citer
plusieurs points d'interrogation
récurrence qui concerne les réseaux
sociaux à la fin de l'année 2021 les
Facebook file révélés par France Hogen
avait permis de lever un coin du voile
sur l'impact d'Instagram sur les jeunes
l'étude interne réalisée par facebook
révélez ainsi qu'Instagram avait un
impact nocif sur l'image corporelle et
bien-être des adolescentes
si des études similaires ont peut-être
été menées par TikTok elle n’ont pas à
ce stade été révélé vous venez vous-même
de dire que le 60 minutes ne venait pas
de nulle part pourriez-vous nous
indiquer les études sur lesquelles vous
avez fondé votre décision et le la
bibliographie
les défis dangereux
[Musique]
ça devrait la chronique régulièrement à
chaque fois on dit ah bah oui c'est on
n'avait pas vu on va supprimer ça et
puis six mois plus tard ça recommence ou
trois mois plus tard avec un autre défi
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé en
Italie je suppose avec la fillette qui
est décédée je lui foulard
il y a eu pas mal de d'autres affaires
de ce type et notamment en France et à
chaque fois TikTok dit ah oui
excusez-nous on va faire très attention
et aujourd'hui ça continue mise à jour
le
8 juin 2023 sur 20 minutes le journal Le
Défi TikTok a dégénéré le 29 mars
dernier à Cergy plusieurs adolescents
ont décidé de sonner aux portes
d'inconnu avant de partir en courant le
tout en filmant la scène pour les
besoins d'une sonnerie partie un jeu
lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
je sais pas si c'est le vote mais je
crois que c'est le vote mais comme le
raconte la Gazette du Val d'Oise ce
mercredi des habitants n'ont visiblement
pas apprécié leur petit manège et le
temps est monté des jeunes alors
agresser trois riverains deux d'entre
eux aurait été des victimes de coup de
pointe troisième c'est fracturer la
cheville
jeunes suspects ont pris la fuite avant
l'arrivée des policiers etc etc
d'après nos confrères des vidéos
retrouvées dans les téléphones montrent
notamment l'agression d'un livre les
jeunes qui auraient reconnu en partie
des faits ont été présentés à juge des
enfants vous en êtes où sur les sur les
défis dangereux
alors sur les défis dangereux
je pense que le
évidemment nos équipes de modération
sont mobilisées sur dès que dès qu'un
défi
émerge on a la chance d'avoir des
associations avec lesquelles on
travaille qui sont extrêmement
utiles dont la gestion et la
visibilité et la prise de conscience de
l'existence de ces défis on a parlé de
l'enfance et enfance font partie de ces
signalures de confiance avec lesquels on
travaille on en a beaucoup d'autres
et je dirais que ce qui fait notre force
c'est aussi notre capacité à réagir très
rapidement sur sur ces sujets là et puis
d'apprendre et de fournir des ressources
pour accompagner les jeunes sur la
dangerosité de ces défis alors le jeu
des sonneries est peut-être un peu moins
grave que le jeu du foulard mais en tout
cas le jeu du foulard
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on a
appris et quand vous tapez aujourd'hui
sur l'application jeux du foulard vous
allez avoir des ressources qui vous sont
proposées des informations qui vont vous
expliquer pourquoi
c'est un défi dangereux pour quoi il ne
faut pas le faire et donc on n'avait pas
accès évidemment à des contenus ou à des
jeunes en train de faire le jeu du
foulard mais vous avez en tout cas tout
un tout une explication de oui c'est une
bêtise
donc nous notre enjeu il est évidemment
de fournir ce type de ressources sur
chaque jeu dangereux
identifié et d'être le plus rapide à
supprimer ses contenus de la plateforme
et ça c'est c'est une obsession de nos
équipes de modération pour protéger
évidemment les mineurs
merci
le filtre bold glamour je fais pas de
dessin vous connaissez ça aussi bien moi
mieux que moi la présidente de
l'association Guy en France avec
laquelle d'ailleurs je crois que vous
travaillez notamment
s'interroge dans un article du Figaro
sur le fait d'interdire ces filtres
mineurs on en connaît toutes les
conséquences quel est votre position
là-dessus
alors le sujet de
des filtres et est un sujet extrêmement
intéressant parce que
au-delà des filtres beauté qui
effectivement sur lequel on peut avoir
un peu un point de vue et un point de
vue
personnel je dirais que c'est c'est pas
l'usage
de la plateforme c'est à dire qu'en fait
le la plateforme TikTok le principe
c'est l'authenticité c'est à dire de
faire des contenus on va raconter une
histoire authentique et on va se montrer
sous un jour authentique si on est dans
une posture ou dans un jeu
c'est pas un contenu qui devient viral
parce que c'est pas ce que les gens
attendent donc c'est vrai que le sujet
des filtres sur les vidéos il est il est
probablement moins impactant que sur de
la photo mais je dirais que c'est filtre
beauté ne sont probablement pas des
sujets de popularité ou de viralité
réellement sur la plateforme c'est pas
ce qui va générer le plus de vues sur la
plateforme et le sujet de l'effet il est
important pour nous pour améliorer une
expérience et et c'est amélioration
d'expérience et nous permet de plutôt de
nous transposer dans un univers de nous
transposer dans dans une thématique
plus que sur des sujets de finalement de
beauté
probablement je voudrais que je vérifie
s'il est aussi il est toujours sur la
plateforme je dirais que pour qu'on le
supprime il faudrait qu'on ait une
raison majeure après à titre personnel
je suis pas complètement fan de ce
filtre mais ça n'engage que moi donc
tant qui crée pas de dégâts ou de
dommages ou qu'il y a pas de de plainte
je sais pas trop comment répondre à
votre question à vrai dire mais en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la finalité sur Tik Tok c'est pas de ce
qu'on appelle le beauty shot c'est à
dire que c'est on vient pas sur Tik Tok
et on n'est pas populaire sur Tik Tok
parce qu'on fait des vidéos on est joli
ou des photos parce qu'on est jolie
j'ai l'impression que pour vous tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil
les psychologues les chirurgiens
esthétiques etc nous disent il y a un
problème majeur il y a maintenant plus
de d'adolescents de 18 à 20 ans qui
consultent qui font des consultations
chirurgie esthétiques que de personnes
âgées
les
psychologues nous disent que l'époque de
construction identitaire l'adolescence
Québec de construction identitaire
entraîne à partir de ces schémas de ses
filtres des problèmes majeurs de
dysmorphophobie
sans compter les problèmes de dépression
etc c'est un vrai fléau
j'ai l'impression que vous regardez ça
depuis votre salle depuis votre bureau
un Tik Tok en regardant
une version complètement théorique je
peux vous dire que nous pas seulement
d'ailleurs avec les associations etc
mais dans notre boulot de sénateurs
auprès de la population générale on est
en permanence
le problème des réseaux sociaux et en
particulier et très très fréquemment
au point que comment dire mis en exergue
et vous ne vous rendez pas compte du
nombre de personnes supposons que ça
représente 1% de vos centres pour cent
quand vous avez 20 millions
d'utilisateurs en France c'est des
centaines de milliers de personnes je
crois que vous ne vous rendez pas compte
de ça sur les filtres sur les les
identifications à des des comment dire
à des
canons de beauté etc c'est un vrai moi
je vous dis mon sentiment c'est que
c'est un vrai fléau et que vous n'avez
pas l'air de le mesurer en fait je suis
étonné que bol de l'amour soit toujours
et ce genre de filtre soit toujours sur
l'appli alors permettez-moi juste de
vérifier parce que je n'en suis pas
complètement certaine donc on va
vérifier s'il est toujours sur
l'application
après ce que je veux juste vous dire
c'est qu'en fait sur TiK ToK on vient
pour se divertir on vient pour s'amuser
et on n'est pas sur
sur une vidéo où on va se s'embellir
entre guillemets si elle n'a pas
d'histoire elle n'a pas d'intérêt elle
ne sera pas virale donc en fait le
filtre en tant que tel il est
intéressant s'il apporte une expérience
donc on a des filtres qui sont des
filtres de quiz on a des filtres qui
nous permettent de d'enfiler le casque
des Daft Punk et de se mettre en scène
quand il y a une notion de gamification
ces filtres ont une efficacité virale un
filtre qui embellit pas vraiment
d'histoire à il y a pas vraiment
d'histoires à raconter donc en termes de
viralité je questionne la viralité de de
ces filtres mais bien sûr qu'on minimise
pas le l'impact l'impact de ça vous
savez par paralylisme des formes le
milieu de la mode il y a une quinzaine
d'années a fini par se sentir dans
l'obligation de de mettre en oeuvre des
codes de bonnes conduite sur le fait de
ne pas mettre en avant des mannequins
dont la maigreur extrême viendrait
imprimer des canons de beauté qui font
du dégât après psychologiquement
donc la prise de conscience et la
possibilité de considérer qu'on a un
rôle volontariste sur la diffusion de
telle ou tel type de valeur
pourrait parfaitement et personne vous
le reprocherez au contraire venir
spontanément et si ça n'est pas à une
plateforme de prendre la décision seule
de crainte que les annonceurs on les
abonnés à y voir ailleurs
il y a une responsabilité sociale qui
est énorme
et qui est le corollaire de votre succès
quoi qu'il pendant de votre succès
sur un porteur
il vérifie Game Boy
alors les problèmes de
désinformation
newsguard que vous connaissez
probablement note une forte présence de
contenu faux sur TikTok 20% des vidéos
apparaissant dans les résultats de
recherche du réseau Tic-Toc sur les
principaux sujets d'actualité
contiennent de la més information
d'après newsga selon Shin Labé
l'explication tiendrate à la modération
majoritairement faite par intelligence
artificielle et un algorithme qui
valoriserait des contenus faisant réagir
évidemment vous êtes pas les seuls
et donc davantage et donc davantage les
contenus faux
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez deuxième
question il s'agissant de la modération
des contenus pourquoi a-t-il fallu
attendre les signalements de newsgard
pour que ce soit retiré les contenus
glorifiant les actes d'exaction du
groupe Wagner qui contrevenait pourtant
clairement aux règles d'utilisation du
Tik Tok cette défaillance elle aussi
s'explique-t-elle par le recours à une
modération par l'intelligence
artificielle et non à une modération
humaine
voilà deux questions
oui
Michael je vais aller me
montre cette information dans une autre
audition
newsgard 40 minutes pour tomber sur une
fausse info
alors
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas cette
étude de news gare je n'en connais pas
le la fiabilité
concrètement ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'en matière de désinformation
c'est je vous parlais au départ de nos
rêves communautaires la désinformation
fait partie de ces communautaires hyper
clair que on n'autorise pas la
désinformation et donc à ce titre les
équipes de modération suppriment les
contenus qui sont de la désinformation
on travaille avec des vérificateurs de
fait qui font partie de l'international
fact checking network dont l'AFP qui
nous permet de vérifier un certain
nombre de faits
donc aujourd'hui
on travaille main dans la main avec
l'AFP notamment pour nous assurer que
les contenus sont sont des contenus
juste et vrai et effectivement on
supprime tous les contenus qui sont de
l'ordre de la désinformation
on a pris un certain nombre d'actions au
moment de la guerre en Ukraine aussi qui
qui sont des actions intéressantes qui
permettent de labelliser les comptes de
médias qui sont contrôlés par l'État
donc aujourd'hui on en a plus de 120 de
compte médias qui sont labellisés par
les ils sont labellisés médias contrôlés
par l'État qui permettent de aux
utilisateurs d'avoir aussi une lecture
plus juste de des informations qui sont
diffusées par ces par ces comptes China
Daily fait partie de ces de ses comptes
sur la guerre en
Ukraine
et sur le sujet de la Russie en
particulier Tik Tok a été la première
plateforme à bannir suite à la demande
de l'Union européenne
Spoutnik et Russia Today donc on a eu
une action
directe de bannissement de ses comptes
et la plus rapide parmi toutes les
plateformes donc je crois qu'on est on
montre quand même par un certain nombre
de gestes notre mobilisation sur le
sujet j'ai probablement des chiffres à
vous partager sur le nombre de contenus
de fake news qui ont été supprimés
[Musique]
en termes de désinformation on a
supprimé
4191 vidéos
qui était des fake news dont 78% qui ont
été identifiés de manière proactive
donc voilà et nous vérificateurs de fait
on a plus de d'une trentaine de
vérificateurs de faits qui vérifie
l'ensemble de ces faits ce qui se passe
aussi c'est que on sur certaines vidéos
sur lesquelles
on a des doutes et on n'a pas on
n'arrive pas à un accord avec les
vérificateurs de fer on fait apparaître
une mention qui dit
fait une vidéo non
partageant des faits non confirmés donc
on a aussi la capacité de faire
apparaître ces mentions là donc on a on
est on est
particulièrement actif et puis on est
très sensible aussi dans des périodes
sensibles comme les périodes d'élection
par exemple les élections
présidentielles on a travaillé avec le
SIG pour nous assurer que on fournissait
toutes les informations utiles aux
utilisateurs avec
un guide électoral avec des informations
sur ou voter comment voter comment faire
une procuration etc qui semble-t-il a
été utile parce qu'on a eu plus d'un
million trois de
personnes qui ont utilisé ces ressources
donc voilà on est vraiment mobilisé sur
le sujet et et c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un sujet qui est pris au
sérieux donc je sais pas
quelles sont ces stats et d'où sort
cette étude mais en tout cas
je peux vous dire qu'en terme de de
procédure et de partenaires on est
plutôt assez bien équipé
merci
en 2021 le groupement des associations
européennes de défense des consommateurs
ont déposé une plainte auprès de la
Commission européenne contre Tik Tok
elle lui reprochait notamment d'exposer
les utilisateurs mineurs à des vidéos
sexuellement suggestives dès leur
inscription est-ce que vous savez où on
est cette plainte
je ne sais pas où on est ces plainte en
tout cas je peux vous dire que ce type
de vidéo est contraire à nos règles nos
règles communautaires et donc modérer et
que ça fait partie des premiers contenus
qui vont être supprimés par l'algorithme
puisque l'algorithme va
identifier très rapidement que ces
contenus ne sont non conformes donc
[Musique]
je peux pas vous dire où on en est sur
ces plaintes mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'en tout cas c'est contenu
sont ne sont absolument pas acceptables
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle sexuellement
suggestif parce que quand je suis je
n'étais pas utilisateur de Tik Tok mais
j'y suis allé pour les besoins de
l'enquête je peux vous dire que quand
vous soyez paix les comptes sexuellement
suggestifs
tout dépend de la définition mais selon
ma définition ils arrivent extrêmement
vite et ils sont là
mais je veux bien vous croire à ce
moment là je vous encourage à les
signaler vous appuyez sur la vidéo
pendant une à deux secondes et vous
pouvez signaler et vous avez une petite
case qui s'appelle nudité et et voilà
c'est parfois plus si je suis
sexuellement quand c'est pas de la
nudité totale que quand s'en est je
reconnais que c'est pas de la nudité
totale mais ça veut pas dire que c'est
moins sujet et c'est pas acceptable donc
effectivement c'est ça doit être modéré
est-ce que vous vendez vos données
et acquis non nous ne vendons pas nos
données les données sont utilisées
uniquement pour
nos propres besoins servir nos campagnes
publicitaires ou travailler l'expérience
utilisateur
est-ce que la pratique du Shadow banning
est toujours en usage sur TikTok et
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire son
intérêt toujours en usage qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par Shadow banning le fait
de
ne pas supprimer
des vidéos mais de les mettre de le
contraire du meeting si vous voulez
c'est à dire le fait de les
rendre moins visibles
gradés de façon que elle soit beaucoup
moins vue voir très très peu en fait ça
c'est
l'algorithme qui qui va le mettre en
place pour des vidéos que l'on considère
comme nocive si répétée c'est-à-dire des
vidéos sur de des vidéos de régime des
vidéos de fitness intense ou des vidéos
qui si elles sont proposées dans la page
pour toi
de façon répétée elles peuvent être
pour le bien-être mental de
l'utilisateur
mauvaise donc en fait
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça du
Shadow banning en tout cas l'algorithme
va traiter ces vidéos là de façon
différente et les proposer en moins
grand nombre et en tout cas les
intercalés avec d'autres vidéos et puis
le principe de baisser la visibilité
aussi c'est sur des contenus plus
matures donc on en parlait juste avant
des contenus plus matures ils ne seront
pas visibles dans le dans les flux des
mineurs par exemple donc vous avez des
vidéos qui sont catégorisées et selon le
niveau de de maturité elles seront
moins visibles ou pas visibles du tout
pour des moins de 18 ans
que vous avez encore des centaines de
milliers voire des millions
d'adolescents qui annoncent qu'ils ont
30 ans ou 40 ans et qui ont accès à
l'ensemble de votre contenu
malgré vos précautions malgré
l'algorithme malgré les interventions
humaines il y a encore d'ailleurs vous
le signez dans vos statistiques je crois
que la dernière statistiques que j'ai vu
c'est pas rage moins de 13 ans 05
millions donc vous avez encore 500000
c'était une statistique qui date de
quelques mois pas d'aujourd'hui mais pas
vieille vous avez énormément de
d'utilisateurs mineurs qui ont déclaré
et un âge supérieur que vous ne pouvez
pas repérer c'est normal tant qu'il y a
pas un contrôle d'âge par double
anonymisation ou autre donc aujourd'hui
vous avez énormément de
de fin il vous avez énormément de
mineurs qui se font passer comme mesure
que vous ne repérez pas je peux pas vous
dire j'ai pas de stade pour appuyer ce
point-là ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que on va communiquer sur des données
très précises dans le cas du DSA sur sur
nos audiences on sait que on a
la moitié de notre audience qui a
plus de 25 ans
on a concrètement deux tiers de
l'audience qui a entre 18 et 35 ans
donc et toute façon c'est pas trop dans
notre intérêt de de
pas être précis sur ça puisque notre
modèle on en parlait tout à l'heure
notre modèle
publicitaire nécessite d'être
effectivement plus juste sur sur nos
audiences donc
ça fait partie du travail de nos
modérateurs de nous assurer aussi que on
a en tout cas un respect à minima de
l'âge légal des 13 ans et ensuite
c'est compliqué effectivement de dire un
utilisateur tu n'as pas
tu n'as pas 19 ans tu en as 17 mais
peut-être qu'on arrivera effectivement
avec une réflexion collective à avoir un
niveau de contrôle supérieur à celui là
aujourd'hui à celui qu'on a aujourd'hui
à titre personnel est-ce que vous
trouvez normal que les gafam soit
interdits en Chine et TikTok autorisé
partout sauf en Chine d'ailleurs
[Musique]
est interdit dans certains pays je
trouve ça très injuste aussi donc oui
dans l'absolu on Ta philosophiquement je
suis pour la liberté d'usage de parole
et et effectivement que on offre à tous
les utilisateurs du monde entier les
mêmes choix après il y a probablement
des raisons qui me dépassent et je
ne suis probablement pas la personne la
plus compétente pour répondre
précisément à ça
donc si vous êtes pour la liberté de
parole
vous condamnez la censure lourde lourde
lourde du Parti communiste chinois sur
Douilly une société appartenant au même
groupe que le vôtre et sur l'ensemble du
de l'Internet chinois mais puisque vous
êtes pour la liberté de parole je
suppose que vous condamnez je suis
absolument pas experte de du sujet de la
Chine
je ne connais pas cette censure en fait
je ne j'aimerais j'adore me prononcer
sur les sujets que je maîtrise et que je
connais celui-là je ne connais pas donc
je permettais moi de de ne pas me
permettre d'émettre un avis bien sûr que
philosophiquement la censure est une
mauvaise chose
après je ne te permettrai pas de
d'intervenir sur un sujet que je ne
connais pas
vous ne connaissez pas le fait que
douille
vous connaissez douille quand même vous
connaissez ne me dites pas que vous
connaissez pas la censure massive de do
Yin qu'on peut pas trouver une vidéo sur
les Ouigours sur le Tibet etc c'est
perdre tout le monde le sait et vaut
mieux que quiconque
donc je vous demande simplement je pense
pas que vous puissiez vous
réfugier derrière l'explication je ne
connais pas le la situation en Chine je
cette situation on la connaît vous la
connaissez aussi bien que tout le monde
de Guinée massivement censuré je demande
simplement si vous condamnez ça ou pas
visiblement vous n'avez pas l'air de
condamner
je ne sais pas s'il y a la censure sur
doine en Chine je n'ai jamais ouvert
l'application doin en fait donc je vous
lisais les journaux quoi si vous le
savez pas et vous êtes la seule alors je
vois et vous êtes spécialiste des
plateformes
je suis comme saint Thomas je crois que
ce que je vois et en l'occurrence
l'application de Win je ne l'ai jamais
ouverte donc je je ne sais pas s'il y a
de la censure
je n'en sais rien mais vous savez quand
même je suppose que Tik Tok est interdit
en Chine je sais surtout que Tik Tok
opère dans tous les pays du monde sauf
en Chine après il ne perd pas parce que
vous avez décidé de ne pas opérer mais
parce qu'il est interdit en Chine et
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal est-ce
que vous condamnez le fait que soit rien
en Chine c'est quand même ennuyeux pour
une société ça vous prive de pas mal de
d'utilisateurs potentiels franchement je
n'ai pas le contexte sur sur cette
interdiction ou pas
je ne sais pas je sais pas que ça me
gêne pas c'est à dire que encore une
fois je ne connais pas assez le dossier
pour
pour pouvoir me prononcer le dossier des
Ouigours vous avez entendu parler est-ce
que vous condamnez ce que pas mal
d'experts appellent le génocide des
ouigo en Chine ou en tout cas la
politique de répression vis-à-vis des
Wiko en tant que citoyenne et en tant
que personne oui bien sûr
pour rester dans le sujet j'ai posé la
question ce matin monsieur Garandeau et
comme vous êtes tous les deux
salariés de Tik Tok je voudrais essayer
de vérifier auprès de vous une
information
sur laquelle Tik Tok France n'a pas
donné de réponse la sollicitation de la
journaliste qui l'a publié je vous relie
l'extrait enfin je l'ai lu ce matin
tous les salariés les confirment
il parle des relations question avec la
Chine avec la maison mère donc les
salariés
au dire d'anciens salariés les salariés
au quotidien sont en permanence en
contact avec les employés chinois de
Bike dance qui jouent un rôle clé dans
la validation des projets et des
procédures
je saute certains passages parallèlement
certains salariés ont été briefés sur la
manière dont ils doivent parler de
l'entreprise en public selon les
informations du média spécialisées
guizmodo l'un des principaux
commandements promus par le document et
de contester les liens qu'entretient
TikTok en Europe et que sa maison mère
en Chine ouvrez les guillemets minimiser
by dance minimiser l'association avec la
Chine minimiser l'intelligence
artificielle ferme les guillemets fant
ainsi textuellement partie des éléments
à retenir de ce document celui-ci
propose par ailleurs certains éléments
de langage clé en main comme il y a
beaucoup de désinformations autour
TikTok en ce moment la réalité c'est Tik
Tok n'est même pas disponible en Chine
ma question est simple et sans suspicion
aucune vous êtes là depuis peu de temps
enfin un an
avez-vous été confronté à ces éléments
de langage avez-vous eu en main ou
avez-vous été destinataire d'un document
interne ou de tout autre façon qui qui
vous qui soit similaire de prix ou de
loin avec ce que relate cette
journaliste non voilà mais je vous pose
la question également vous pouvez pas
répondre pour les autres donc vous non
très bien
non j'aurais une remarque
sur le temps passé vous nous dites tout
à l'heure il y a 25% des il y a 75 % des
des jeunes concernés qui conservent
l'alerte mais comme je vous l'ai fait
remarquer ça nous dit pas combien de
personnes grosso modo si conforme dans
les minutes qui suivent
de la même façon sur les infoges ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est que que vous
ayez supprimé tant de dizaines de
milliers de vidéos que vous puissiez
démontrer que sur tel ou tel sujet vous
avez pris soin d'invisibiliser un mot
dièse ou de supprimer certains mots
dièse ou que l'algorithme ne propose pas
dans des bulles de filtres n'enfermer
les gens sur sur des comment dire des
sujets précis qui font l'objet de
beaucoup de mes informations c'est une
chose mais ce que nous n'avons pas et de
la même façon il faudrait que vous ayez
une personne tierce extérieure qui
puisse vous auditer pour pouvoir
objectiver tout ça ce que nous n'avons
pas c'est le fait de savoir combien il
en reste à la fin ce que vous êtes une
entreprise jeune mais tant qu'il y a
trois ans on est plus évaluer que vous
avez tant de pourcentage de d'infox ou
de mes informations en ligne newsgard
qui est quand même assez reconnu sur la
place du point de vue européen quand il
nous dit en mai 40 minutes en moyenne
pour tomber sur une une info fausse sur
une afox ou une mes informations
ils essaient d'objectiver bon vous
pourriez faire une contre expertise ou
demander à un autre de répondre à ça ce
qui nous manque dans ce que vous nous
dites c'est pas tant le fait de savoir
que vous avez des modérateurs
heureusement vous avez des modérateurs
mais c'est la question du résultat la
fin c'est dans des politiques publiques
ce qui compte c'est pas de dire que
l'État informe les gens sur la question
de la cigarette c'est de regarder
combien on a de cancers combien de
personnes qui se mettent à fumer combien
on a qui arrête et ça c'est des
questions statistiques de quasiment de
politique publique et c'est ça qui nous
c'est ça qui nous intéresse ça je
voulais vous dire et qui sont
probablement disponibles dans nos
rapports de transparence donc on va on
va regarder parce que dans la mesure où
la désinformation fait partie de nos
règles communautaires et que l'on combat
la désinformation et que donc ces
contenus sont modérés et par notre
algorithme nos outils et par nos
modérateurs humains on communique à
travers ces rapports de transparence
trimestrielle l'ensemble des contenus
qu'on supprime et comment et à quelle
rapidité on les supprime
et dont
24 heures et par signalement etc donc on
a un certain nombre de données dans ces
rapports de transparence qui qui sont
et combien il en reste parce que de la
même façon qu'il n'y a rien d'infamment
à avoir fait l'objet d'une cyberattaque
avoir perdu telle ou tel type de données
à cette refait avoir par tel ou telle
porte dérobée sont des choses sur
lesquelles il faut communiquer pour que
ça bénéficie aux autres de la même façon
il est impossible à 1 milliard et
quelques utilisateurs que vous n'en
n'ayez pas et je pense que personne ne
vous demanderait le zéro faute mais de
savoir que tous les moyens sont mis en
oeuvre et qu'on et qu'on progresse au
fur et à mesure est un élément est un
élément essentiel
il y a une question à laquelle j'ai pas
eu de réponse ce matin et Monsieur
Garandeau aimablement envoyé vers vous
est-ce que vous payez des journalistes
pour qu'ils prennent soin de faire du
contenu sur Tik Tok
non d'accord
c'est pas notre modèle en fait notre
modèle nous c'est d'accompagner des
quand on a enfin journaliste ça peut
s'apparenter à une personnalité publique
une personnalité publique elle va venir
sur la plateforme parce que elle a un
enjeu de visibilité avant de en livre à
faire connaître un spectacle donc pour
répondre à la question à laquelle n'est
pas répondu dans un article de la
semaine dernière je crois le monde ou
Médiapart c'est plutôt le monde par
exemple quand un journaliste qui est sur
le service public sur Inter et sur
France 5 par ailleurs de très très
bonnes émissions lorsque Augustin
Trapenard publie autant de vidéos qu'il
en publie sur Tik Tok en expliquant je
suis allé regarder Tik Tok ça permet ce
site Tik Tok ça permet cela enfin si il
est pas payé il a tort entre nous le le
modèle économique c'est que une personne
publique par exemple lui ce qu'il en
retire comme on dit en sociologie don
contre dons il n'y a jamais rien de
gratuit dans la vie mais ça peut ne pas
être monétisé le contredon c'est la
visibilité pour la personne publique et
en fait c'est un échange de procédés je
sais pas s'ils sont de bons de mauvais
procédés mais c'est un échange de
procédés c'est là qui est le modèle
économique entre la recherche de
visibilité pour un une personne publique
ou un journaliste ou et vous la qualité
du contenu c'est ça le marché en fait le
ce qui est intéressant avec Augustin
Trapenard c'est que il a compris en fait
qu'il fallait pas opposer les modèles et
que en fait grâce à TiK ToK on pouvait
faire lire des gens et le faire lire des
jeunes et donc il est arrivé très
naturellement sur sur la plateforme et
effectivement parce que c'est un super
ambassadeur parce qu'il est crédible et
parce que en fait il est il est juste
dans ce qu'il fait on a décidé
effectivement de le faire parler dans
notre campagne de communication sur
booktok donc on a eu une campagne de
marque où là dans le cas de cette
campagne publicitaire là pour le coup il
a été rémunéré mais pourquoi on a choisi
Augustin ah on a choisi Augustin parce
que il était présent sur la plateforme
et que il était crédible sur le sujet du
livre donc ensuite il est arrivé dans
une campagne marketing mais c'est pas
l'inverse qui s'est produit
vous avez dans le cadre d'une campagne
qu'est-ce que vous avez une campagne
publicitaire mais l'accent sur un sujet
par exemple en fait on a acheté du média
pour un certain montant on a fait un
spot télé dans lequel on explique en
fait
c'est vous qui allez payer du temps de
publicité sur d'autres médias donc on
indigne voilà exactement dans certains
ouvrages ou certains articles sur Tik
Tok le fait que visiblement il y a
quelques plateformes ou quelques
comment dire des personnes qui diffusent
du contenu qui ont regretté après coup
de ne pas avoir qui ont comment dire qui
ont trouvé que finalement Tik Tok les
arrangés eux aussi même si vous étiez
concurrent parce que vous payez du temps
d'écran chez eux enfin c'est comme quand
je dis n'importe quoi si si un groupe
quelque chose qui appartient au groupe
TF1 se met à faire de la pub sur Canal+
on va chez le concurrent pour chercher
on achète sur Instagram on achète sur
Youtube on achète sur toutes les
plateformes et donc dans ce cadre là
vous avez fait une campagne de
communication pour booktok sur d'autres
supports et vous avez et ce journaliste
on a indemnités
absolument je comprends qu'il n'est pas
voulu répondre à l'article la semaine
dernière parce que même si ce que vous
décrivez dans un cadre précis vous venez
nous le décrire de manière assez précise
et claire
je comprends l'enthousiasme en
l'occurrence c'est c'est il faut quand
même refaire l'histoire c'est à dire
qu'en fait Augustin Trapenard est arrivé
sur la plateforme comme plein d'autres
sont arrivés sur la plateforme comme
Joël Dicker c'était arrivé sur la
plateforme comme Antoine Dupont comme
plein de d'athlètes plein de comme Eric
et Ramzy soirée sur la plateforme comme
et en fait ils y viennent parce que
c'est aujourd'hui on est un média et que
on est en outil au service de plein de
choses la grande librairie à son compte
sur sur la plateforme libération arrive
sur la plateforme le monde fait un
travail formidable sur la plateforme
vous pourriez même parler de certaines
institutions parlementaires
j'osais pas vous faire la front mais on
a adoré leur contenu en tout cas
la traîne westanderson était très bien
trouvée puisque c'est la tendance du
moment il est important pour les gens de
savoir quand il y a la petite mention
publique reportage dans la moindre
gazette locale qui est payé pour dire du
bien qui n'est pas payé pour dire du
bien j'entends ce que vous me dites
monsieur Trapenard n'est pas payé
aujourd'hui quand il s'enflamme dans ses
vidéos TikTok pour booktok mais comme on
dit chez nous on dit chez moi ça a eu
payé enfin ça a eu payé c'est une
indemnisation qui est somme toute
modeste et vous aurez sans doute
probablement accès à un moment
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je voudrais juste quand même rétablir
l'effet c'est il a été choisi sur cette
campagne parce qu'il est crédible sur le
sujet booktok parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'il publie et qui publie des
choses de qualité et qu'il a une
relation hyper intéressante avec des
créateurs booktok qui ont d'ailleurs
fait sensation au festival du livre de
Paris parce que voilà il a il arrive
aujourd'hui comme toutes les maisons
d'édition on a 60 maisons d'édition sur
la plateforme qui aujourd'hui sont
crédibles sur le sujet donc Augustin il
a été choisi dans notre campagne de
communication parce que il est il est
crédible sur le sujet mais mais c'est
pas il fait pas des contenus Tik Tok
forcés voilà d'accord
alors une dernière pour la route merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président non c'est
un sujet moi qui me préoccupe et j'ai
posé aussi la question ce matin c'est la
question de la cybersécurité extérieure
externe de l'application et et de Tik
Tok
vous êtes peut-être au courant de ce qui
s'est passé il y a quelques semaines
pour une application de commerce en
ligne chinoise pin du haut du haut qui
s'est retrouvé avec un malware qui
permettait à certaines personnes
d'extraire les données de l'extérieur à
la fois sur l'application en Chine mais
aussi sur le développement international
que connaît cette société donc moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la question de
savoir si aujourd'hui Tik Tok reste ce
risquerait à transférer
illicitement ces données vers la Chine
ouvert je dirais à la demande des
autorités chinoises je pense qu'il y a
un risque qui serait quand même
commercial extrêmement lourd la question
c'est celui de la vulnérabilité de tout
les supports et toutes les bases de
données notamment la vôtre qui compte
des milliards d'informations
personnelles de la part d'attaque
extérieure de groupe de hackers de gens
ont dit que les données personnelles
sont leurs noirs ou leurs blancs de la
société de l'économie actuelle
quelle est les moyens j'imagine
important que vous mettez en termes de
sécurisation de vos données et question
que je pose allons me dire mais c'est
compliqué de le dire est-ce que vous
êtes victime d'actins d'attaque est-ce
que vous êtes capable de les contenir
est-ce que vous les recensez est-ce
qu'elles font l'objet aussi d'un
signalement parce qu'en France et
allemand vraiment une base de données
aussi importante que la vôtre est
attaquée on signale un Annecy qui donne
son aide c'est pas une honte au
contraire pendant longtemps beaucoup
d'entreprises renonçaient à le signaler
parce que on craignait le préjudice
d'images aujourd'hui c'est quand même
mieux de savoir que tous les jours
d'ailleurs en France des centaines de
milliers de données
s'envolent on ne sais où par le biais
d'attaque et pas seulement d'orange et
de vol pur et simple de donner sans sans
destruction de ce qui se passe donc quel
est l'état aujourd'hui de la
cybersécurité le fait moi je le crois
de bonne foi les dirigeants quand ils
disent on les transfère pas on respecte
les règles internationales sur les
transferts données mais la capacité à
résister à une attaque extérieure c'est
pas la même chose que donner ses données
que de laisser la porte ouverte avec le
risque d'être cambriolé ou quels sont
les serrures quelles sont les bars de
fer qui sont mis devant les fenêtres vu
l'importance des des données que vous
détenez
c'est une question évidemment
stratégique hyper intéressante mais très
technique et je ne suis pas moi-même une
experte de la cybersécurité ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que j'ai le
sentiment quand même que avec la mise en
place du projet Clover que
Erica on doit dû vous expliquer ce matin
avec la souveraineté numérique avec un
tiers de confiance qui sera annoncé
prochainement qui qui va sécuriser aussi
tout le stockage de données personnelles
en Europe
on va cranter quelque chose aussi en
matière de cybersécurité
après je évidemment je pense que le
sujet de la cybersécurité concerne
toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui
puisque toutes les entreprises
manipulent de la donnée donc ce serait
bien improbable que ce soit pas un sujet
important chez nous également mais je
n’étends pas expert du sujet je ne
m'aventurerai pas dans une réponse
hasardeuse et incomplète c'est pour ça
que je vous posais le cas de la dopine
du haut du haut qui est une grande
société chin la base et internationale
et qui est très soucieuse de
cybersécurité elle-même s'est retrouvée
plus le coffre-fort est grand plus il
attire des convoitises elles-mêmes c'est
visiblement trouver chargé d'un malware
et avec des défites massives de données
qui a fallu reconnaître pour le dire
autrement depuis que vous êtes là vous
n'avez pas eu connaissance de d'une
attaque massive ou très préjudiciable
qui aurait touché tip-top ou TikTok
France dans les années précédentes
depuis que vous êtes là pour ce que vous
pouvez dire vous depuis mon arrivée chez
Tik Tok je n'en ai jamais entendu parler
et après je pense qu'il y a aussi c'est
probablement et là je vais peut-être
m'aventurer sur un sujet que je maîtrise
mal mais dans la mesure où justement on
a pas vraiment d'API ouverte et que les
apéines sont vertes que pour des
chercheurs aujourd'hui vous minimiser
minimiser aussi les risques c'est à dire
que le vous risque de cyber ils sont
aussi plus importants quand vous avez
plus d'API ouverte donc mais vraiment je
n'en ai absolument pas entendu parler
donc je suis désolé
souhaitez-vous rajouter juste pour
question quelle est l'entité chez vous à
quel niveau s'occupe de la cybersécurité
globale c'est-à-dire est-ce que ça se
passe au Royaume-Uni est-ce que ça se
passe aux
îles Caïmans est-ce que ça se passe à
Los Angeles qui
assure globalement parce que c'est pas
un travail décentralisé c'est un travail
quand même qui mérite beaucoup de moyens
donc qui est en charge de ça le
géographiquement en tous les cas
je vais vérifier cette information j'ai
envie de vous dire Cormac kinan qui note
patron la sécurité au niveau global donc
je j'imaginerai que c'est lui mais je
préfère qu'on vérifie et qu'on revienne
vers vous avec la bonne information y
a-t-il quelque chose que vous auriez
souhaité ajouter avant qu'on
termine cette audition
peut-être juste vous dire on a assez peu
parlé de contenu et
on je voulais quand même repréciser le
fait que les équipes de Tik Tok en
France sont vraiment mobilisés sur
l'accompagnement des marques sur des
secteurs prioritaires que sont la
musique le sport le divertissement l'art
de vivre les contenus éducatifs
et et que notre engagement est sincère
et que quand on choisit des événements
auxquels s'associer que ce soit le
Festival du Livre de Paris le Festival
de Cannes qu'on soutiennent
Roland-Garros qu'on soutiennent le Tour
de France qu'on soutienne le l'événement
de eSport récents le majeur de
Counter-Strike ce sont des engagements
qui sont sincères et qui sont vraiment
portés par une compréhension de notre
communauté de ce qu'elle attend donc
voilà vous avez le droit de pas me
croire mais en tout cas je voulais quand
même vous le dire parce que c'est ce qui
anime le travail des équipes elles sont
mobilisées à
s'engager sincèrement sur sur faire
croître cette écosystème et faire
croître cette communauté d'utilisateurs
avec des contenus toujours plus
qualitatifs toujours plus engageant
toujours plus pertinent et voilà c'est
vraiment ce qui nous anime au quotidien
donc voilà je voulais juste rajouter ce
point là je précise que nous sommes donc
il y a un certain nombre d'éléments que
vous avez proposé de nous envoyer par
écrit
si ça nous obligerait si ça pouvait être
sous huit jours
merci à vous merci Madame merci